[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau débat sur tv fil 78
aujourd'hui ce sont les candidats de la
11e circonscription des yvelines qui
vont revenir sur quelques uns des points
de leur programme pour vous aider à
trancher lors du premier tour de scrutin
le dimanche 11 juin et vous le voyez ils
sont très à se présenter sur ce secteur
qui couvre les communes d'elancourt bois
d'arcy
elle s'insère l'école fontenay le fleury
ou encore la verrière et trappes tous
les candidats n'ont pas pu ou pas
souhaité participer à cette émission
notamment en raison des conditions
d'organisation pour des contraintes
techniques vous le savez nous ne pouvons
pierre à part recevoir simultanément
tous les candidats en plateau mireille
brugnaut pour le front a libéré son
suppléant nicolas bonnaire ont du coup
annulé leur participation pour cette
raison il y aura deux plateaux ce soir
pour commencer autour de cette table
jean michel fourgous pour les
républicains bonsoir la face avoue
sandrine grands comme bonsoir vous êtes
responsable départemental du parti
socialiste et vous représenter
aujourd'hui benoît hamon candidat lui
aussi député sortant et pour représenter
aussi sa suppléante puisque aucun des
deux ne pouvait être présent l uc
miserait bonsoir pour le front de gauche
le parti communiste français mathilde
andraud et bonsoir front national
mathurin lévis pour la france insoumise
bonsoir à vous et enfin silvia quandt
albi bonsoir pour tous debout à la
france je rappelle que votre temps de
parole seront bien évidemment
chronométrés l'équité s'appliquera au
mieux l'égalité au maximum les temps de
parole régulièrement sa fiche et on va
faire un premier tour de table vous en
avez l'habitude maintenant avec cette
question simple pourquoi les électeurs
devraient vous faire confiance pourquoi
devrait-il vous accorder leur voix on
commence avec jean michel fourgous on
commencera dans ce sens là l'émission et
on conclura inverse
voilà allez-y ben parce que pouvait
laisser loeb au micro je me bats sur
l'emploi ou savez on
on construit des incubateurs qu'on
développe sur sur cette circonscription
sûre notamment l'agglomération de saint
quentin
ça crée de l'emploi saeed motion aux
jeunes à créer des entreprises on
accélère donc la montée en puissance de
nos jeunes
deuxièmement il faut bien sûr renforcer
les formations notamment
il faut développer ces écoles de codage
cette école du numérique aujourd'hui
qu'ils préparent me sens une vraie
révolution et qui sont très bon levier
pour la croissance
donc moi je me base sur ces écoles mais
c'est des décisions si nationale et puis
bien sûr sur la sécurité enfin sur
l'innovation où certaines zones
d'innovation très importante
moi je travaille sur le projet de la
sécurité du futur comité d'agglomération
avec toutes les dernières technologies à
la différence de beaucoup de grands
thèmes mais c'est surtout l'innovation
qui est donc le manger et l'innovation
ça doit être coordonnée en national
c'est du local et du national pourquoi
voter pour votre candidat que vous
représentez aujourd'hui benoît hamon
député sortant excuser les deux
candidats mais c'était sur une réunion
publique à elancourt puisque comme nous
n'avons pas pu avoir la salle de l'hôtel
de ville que le maire n'a pas souhaité
visiblement nous nous prêter alors
qu'ici à derry attribué deux fois il a
fallu faire en extérieur il serait plus
d'intérêt juste juste deux secondes
avant de commencer les hostilités et
elles sont bien donnés en extérieur
public à elancourt donc on a un candidat
qui est connu dans la circonscription
qui est qui et solide qui a une voix qui
porte haut niveau au niveau national et
qui a été efficace aussi sur le terrain
il a aidé 2
nombreux concitoyens dans des blocs et
des problèmes personnels on a des
milliers de personnes qui sont venues sa
permanence qui l'a aidé et il a aidé des
entreprises il a aidé à pontenet le
déploiement de la fibre donc on a
affaire à quelqu'un de solide et
efficace et qui a une voix qui compte
bonsoir ce qui marque un peu ce scrutin
c'est notamment la défiance quand c'est
pas la désespérance et donc nous on a
axé toute notre
démarche on n'a pas fait de réunions
publiques mais plus des contacts en
direct avec la population pour essayer
de rétablir cette confiance qui est
nécessaire
on en a besoin parce que le progrès
social c'est quelque chose de possible
on a les financements pour simplement
c'est dans le cadre de la répartition
des richesses et des choix politiques
qui seront faits qu on ira vers du
progrès social ou pas tout laisse à
penser qu'on va vers la régression
sociale en continu on nous parle de
renouveau avec ce nouveau président de
la république
en réalité c'est la continuité voire le
retour à valéry giscard d'estaing donc
de cette droite là on n'a pas besoin on
a besoin d'une vraie politique de gauche
at il deux endroits pour le front
national
l'élection de monsieur macro un grand
coup de marketing et l'arrivée en fait
sur le terrain de candidats dont le
point commun est certainement le le
suivisme derrière ce nouveau président
candidat parmi lesquels d'ailleurs on
trouve certains
kim est vraiment la france second plan
je pense et je crains qu on entérine une
logique de la même logique du balancé de
droite gauche on l'a vu pendant des
années qui ajuste effacé la france
progressivement et donc cette logique en
fait quand lorsqu'on est dans l'intérêt
national vient au second plan il est né
les plus pauvres entre 1 et caen alors
que l'aide de le coup là le président se
retrouve avec une logique de clientèle
et sa clientèle à lui cédé petite élite
mondialisée
concrètement il faut aller défendre les
français et je pense que donner les
pleins pouvoirs aux grands gourous du
penser printemps n'est clairement pas
une chance pour la france et donc il est
nécessaire d'envoyer à l'assemblée des
députés patriotes nature à la vie pour
la france a soumis ce pourquoi les
électeurs doit vous faire confiance
parce que je crois qu'on est on traverse
une période politique est un petit peu
particulière qui se caractérise par
plusieurs crises qu'on est en train
d'affronter aujourd'hui frappe et frappe
notre société la crise écologique dont
pas grand monde ne parle mis à part ceux
qui à gauche pense qu'effectivement on
doit protéger le seul écosystème dans
lequel on peut vivre et donc ça c'est
une priorité absolue la crise
démocratique dont pas grand monde ne
parle également mais qui frappe notre
pays de manière assez sévères et moi je
pense qu'il ya des mesures extrêmement
fortes à prendre pour remettre de la
démocratie dans le fonctionnement de
notre pays ça c'est indispensable par
exemple par un mécanisme qui permet de
révoquer les élus par référendum en
cours de mandat qui est une forme de
contrôle populaire qui peut s'exercer
sur les responsables politiques et enfin
parce qu'on termine cette triste liste
sur une crise extrêmement violente
qu'ait la crise sociale qui frappe notre
pays et qui va être amplifié par les
réformes que porte emmanuel macron j'en
dis un mot maintenant parce que c'est
pas prévu dans le reste de votre
programme et par exemple sur la réforme
du code du travail qui est envisagée par
emmanuel macron c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement violent qui vise à
organiser l'ensemble des négociations
sur le contrat de travail le temps de
travail la rémunération le salaire etc
à l'échelle de l'entreprise c'est une
immense régression pour des millions de
salariés dans notre pays c est un retour
au 19e siècle par ordonnance donc les
uns les autres une carte blanche
après des députés de résistance et donc
des députés de la france un sourire pour
se protéger des mauvais coups que
prépare à manuel ma complet sylvia
cantaluppi pour de bouloc soit je suis
ici pour représenter les idées portées
par nicolas dupont aignan lors de
l'élection présidentielle donc nous
portons des valeurs gaullistes
humanistes sociales qui nous semblent ce
bien en danger dans la prochaine
majorité si elle a lieu
et je voulais surtout dire que en tant
que fille de commerçants et en tant que
personnel hospitalier j'ai une vraie
connaissance de toutes les composantes
de notre circonscription j'y suis j'y
habite depuis toujours quasiment et
voilà il faut d'autres il faut une
opposition nette avec des élus qui soit
différent et en surtout qui est comme
moi un casier judiciaire vierge ce
serait bien tout le monde en face au
temple ce dont je ne doute pas sûr
stable ce plateau bien évidemment mais
c'est une notion qui devrait s'appliquer
tout le monde n'y a pas de voie là on
termine donc ce premier tour de table on
va parler de sécurité c'est la première
thématique qui a été retenue juste
jean-michel fois ou si vous souhaitiez
répondre tout à l'heure à 120 grand
gaube
oui simplement même grands noms mais
toujours dans la sincérité et dans les
jeux de mensonges bien c'est les
attaques personnelles c'est toujours le
même style
or elle n'est pas candidat c'est déjà
difficile bien sûr d'accepter cela elle
vient là pour agresser les candidats
c'est quand même un peu pénible
deuxièmement la salle on a proposé une
salle du conseil municipal vous donc
vous mentez délibérément vous savez vous
ne vous n'étiez pas d'accord sur cette
date visiblement voilà et sur le votre
soirée ce soir elle est même autorisé
alors écoutez on n'a pas autoriser cette
manifestation remplacer les un quartier
mais c'est un quartier complètement
centrale de db secours je vais arriver
glisse sur les atouts les leucatois les
pompiers devaient exprimer
l'un et l'autre sur ce sujet et on
poursuit on reprend le fil de cette
émission vous êtes tous environ à une
minute sur ce match on les vit vous avez
un prix un petit peu plus d'avancé une
minute vingt l'utiliserai un tout petit
peu en dessous 48 secondes de temps de
parole donc c'est vous qui allez
commencer et ouvrir les discussions
autour de cette thématique de la
sécurité ya deux problématiques derrière
ce la sécurité la lutte contre le
terrorisme
on parle sur trappe de 60 à 80 jeunes et
qui seraient partis vers la syrie et
puis il ya aussi la délinquance
au quotidien certaines communes qui ont
fait le choix d'armes et leur police
municipale c'est pas par exemple à
elancourt quelles sont vos propositions
en termes de sécurité et comment vous
jauger de cette problématique sur
notamment la 11e circonscription
alors j'aimerais parler pas simplement
de la sécurité j'aimerais commencer par
la tranquillité publique et là dedans il
ya effectivement la sécurité mais la
sécurité on l'assimilé aussi à la notion
de justice la sécurité déjà il ya
quelque chose d'essentiel c'est la
police de proximité qui a été évacué par
monsieur sarkozy sur laquelle monsieur
hollande n'est pas revenu et ça ça nous
semble essentiel pour travailler à une
meilleure connaissance du terrain et
donc là on a besoin de proximité
donc quand par exemple le président de
la république dit qui a besoin de moins
de fonctionnaires bas nous on dit qui a
besoin de plus de fonctionnaires en ce
qui concerne la sécurité donc pour la
police et la gendarmerie mais également
dans la justice mais également dans bien
d'autres domaines comme l'éducation la
santé etc
au niveau de la justice là encore il
n'ya pas que la sanction il ya aussi la
prévention sur laquelle il faut faire
des efforts particuliers et monsieur
conseiller départemental
il serait fort souhaitable que les
efforts sur la prévention spécialisée
soit revu considérablement à la baisse à
la hausse par dont il ya la prévention
il ya le
la sanction la manière dont elle est
appliquée on sait que nos prisons et on
a une prison dans notre circonscription
donc on sait que nos prisons ne
fonctionne pas bien donc ça c'est
quelque chose sur lequel il faut
travailler aussi parce que sinon comment
travailler sur la récidive et ensuite il
ya aussi un esprit que j'aimerais
rajouter qui est celui de réparation
c'est à dire que quand on a commis un
délit
on devrait aussi le réparer s'est pas
simplement par une peine de prison qu on
le répare et donc sur ces sujets là il
ya énormément à faire
on est très préoccupé et moi j'ai les
deux pieds dedans parce que je suis un
élu de terrain on est très préoccupée
par des situations actuellement entre
jeunes qui s'affrontent
et
et ça c'est eux
dans dans la démarche il faut qu'on
aille beaucoup plus loin
e
allez-y pour barbie était trop certain
temps de parole conclut est juste si
vous souhaitez et sur le terrorisme
international bien
là encore les besoins sont extrêmement
importants c'est vrai que tu rappes par
exemple a été particulièrement touchée
mais tout ça est aussi la conséquence
d'un manque d'investissement sur
l'éducation la culture sur
l'accompagnement pour une famille volet
prévention aussi un accompagnement
social au quotidien pour m'excuserai
résumer votre votre pensée pour vous
laisser du temps de parole pour vous
exprimer après la cl vient quant à lui
puis je vous faire vous écoute aussi sur
la sécurité c'est trois choses d'abord
et avant tout pour essayer de faire un
peu de sécurité dans notre pays il
faudrait commencer par an contrôler nos
frontières donc comme nicolas dupont
aignan je réclame le rétablissement des
frontières pas la fermeture le
rétablissent
deuxièmement comme vous venez de dire on
a une crise on dans notre
circonscription ya plein d'autres
il y a en ce moment il faudrait 40 il
manque 40 mille places de prison
est ce que m'étonne que monsieur focus
ne soit pas davantage au fait de ce
sujet parce que il ya la sécurité et le
bien-être des détenus ce qui est une
chose parce qu'effectivement si on
votait la récidive et faire de la
réparation il faut que nos détenus au
sort de là dans un état correct mais
aussi que le respect des détenus c'est
aussi le respect des conditions de
travail du personnel de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui souffrent énormément
je pense que nous avons poussé des
places pour le savoir voilà
deuxième chose et ensuite ya aussi un
autre assemblée sur les rangs et voilà
et cash de l'administration
pénitentiaire il savait pas si elle
souhaitait qu'on le dise donc je n'en
milieu puis c'est vrai mais je n'ai pas
le dévoiler ce que tu aimes le ciel en
deuxième un deuxième point on a quand
même un certain nombre de mosquées dans
notre circonscription d'ailleurs en
visitant la campagne a pratiquement tous
les cultes de représenter dans notre
circonscription c'est toujours très
intéressant mais au niveau des mosquées
il faudrait peut-être les surveiller
davantage exigé que les prêches soit
fait en français surveillez les imams et
contrôler vraiment tout ce qui se peut
s'y passer parce que autant un lieu de
de culte ne pose aucun aucun problème et
je pense que s'il en faut le nom il n'y
a pas de problème mais il faut vérifier
tout ça parce que c'est quand même le
creuset de violence dont nous sommes
tous des victimes
donc en suivant ce tour de table autour
de cette question de sécurité bien
évidemment les uns les autres vous
pouvez réagir si vous le souhaitez
sandrine gang c'est à vous je ferais
s'afficher dans un instant les temps de
parole comme ça vous pourrez vous
positionnez chacun mais c'est à vous à
présent sur la sécurité on va avoir des
points d'accord sur notamment la police
de proximité notamment à d'ores et déjà
dit que puisque c'est dans un des points
du programme de d'emmanuel macron que ça
ferait partie des dispositions qu'il
voterait si on met la police de
proximité sur le terrain on a besoin
effectivement de recréer du lien et on a
vu un train
récemment entre les habitants et la
police un lien de confiance qui fait que
chacun puisse se parler sans avoir de
peur et et on a besoin aussi de cette
problèmes de proximité pour dans un
souci d'efficacité parce que c'est
c'est absolument indispensable après sur
les coalitions vous avez parlé des
conditions des personnels pénitentiaires
quand les locaux les policiers nous
interpelle il nous parle non pas du
commissariat du futur c'est peut-être
une très bonne chose pendant quelques
années mais dans l'immédiat ce qu'ils
veulent c'est des conditions décentes
pour travailler sais pas si vous avez vu
dans quelles conditions ils travaillent
on nous avait expliqué que ça serait
résolu très rapidement notamment avec
madame pécresse qui arriverait à la
région la réalité quand même beaucoup
plus compliqué je pense que là il ya
vraiment urgence qu'on ne peut pas
laisser du personnel qui rend un service
public à la population travaillent dans
des conditions qui sont déplorables donc
dans la circonscription il ya quelques
heures
il ya quelques points qui sont
absolument de l'économie il ya un
certain nombre de points il faut
absolument mettre non seulement les
moyens humains mais aussi des moyens
financiers pour la rénovation et si vous
souhaitez répondre assez assez agressif
comme ton donc je préfère rester vous
n'êtes pas agressive
enfin c'est insupportable d'avoir
quelqu'un qui n'a rien à faire dans ce
débat qui est là uniquement pour
agresser les autres c'est vraiment alors
je le dit un petit mot sur le comice a
demandé tellancourt d'agglomération bon
effectivement ça comme ça du futur que
j'ai avec des gens très innovant et les
meilleures entreprises françaises à
concerne bien sûr l'ensemble des
communes dont dont les nôtres ici
d'aller attaquer madame pécresse là
dessus elle est venue il ya quelques
mois pour dire qu'elle allait devenir un
tiers du financement du commissariat et
franchement vous n'avez rien fait vous
avez un
vous avez mis le chemin de plus ça
trappe qui explique l'augmentation c'est
une sécurité parce qu'un lien entre le
chômage c'est sur votre bilan est à g
vous venez donner des leçons de morale
maintenant parle du commissariat
d'elancourt qui est plutôt une réussite
qui entraîne beaucoup de gens qui ont
beaucoup d'entreprises innovantes qui
travaillaient dessus qui concerne tout
le monde qui est que tout le monde
demande que vous osiez mettre en cause
vraiment le même décret ce qui vient
proposer de payer un tiers de ce
commissariat alors que vous a rien du
tout c'est quand même c'est quand même
un comble se dit qu'un bon sens de
l'humour très bien leurs propositions en
matière de sécurité juste sur la façon
le débat est en train de s'organiser je
crois vraiment que c'est ce dont les
français ne veulent plus c'est à dire
des vieux partis politiques qui font de
la politique ensemble qui se connaissent
par coeur depuis des décennies des
décennies qui se font une espèce de
petite guéguerre de manière plus ou
moins agressive sur des questions qui
n'intéresse pas grand monde extra fins
vraiment je pense qu'on vient d'assister
la séquence dont les français ne veulent
plus et c'est clairement ce qu'ils ont
entre médicales et de sécurité
oui alors j'y viens fort bien sur la
question de la sécurité j'ai par exemple
un vrai désaccord avec monsieur fourgous
sur la question de la façon dont on
traite le terrorisme le choix qui a été
fait effectivement ces dernières années
ça a été de privilégier l'outil
informatique l'outil numérique au
détriment du renseignement de terrain et
du renseignement humain c'est un échec
retentissant
voilà retentissant et donc il faut
effectivement des hommes et des femmes
pour surveiller les réseaux sociaux les
technologies internet etc
mais on ne remplace pas en matière de
lutte contre le terrorisme le travail
humain qui est fait sur le terrain en
termes de renseignements de
démantèlement des trafics des réseaux
etc etc etc
c'était la grande erreur commise par les
deux gouvernements qui nous ont
précédé mais dupuy saveurs vous et
distribuer les tracts de monsieur
hollande ya cinq ans je m'en souvienne
mois il a été élu que ça a donné quoi là
votre nom mais je ne suis pas membre je
suis monsieur je suis la campagne pose
en utilisant jour de l'an 2000 de mes
débuts
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé je
voudrais terminer sur la question de la
délinquance justement rien c'est ce que
je vous dis vous avez fait les deux
coups des deux gouvernements qui
viennent de se succéder son cours
l'arbre de la situation je reviens sur
un élément qui me paraît important sur
les relations qu'entretiennent
qu'entretient la police et la population
et je crois que là aussi on touche au
coeur du problème on a effectivement une
détérioration de ce lien depuis
plusieurs décennies qui est extrêmement
inquiétante
moi je donne les noms par exemple ici
personne n'en a parlé d' adama traoré de
rémy fraises qui sont deux jeunes de 20
25 ans qui ont été tués lors
d'opérations de police alors lors d'une
opération de maintien de l'ordre
d'arrestation
je crois que c'est symbolique qu'il
existe aujourd'hui dans ce pays des
dysfonctionnements dans la façon dont on
organise le maintien de l'ordre et qu'il
faut y répondre il faut une réponse
politique à ça pour que les citoyens
retrouve de la confiance parce que la
police n'est là non pas pour semer du
désordre de la violence mais pour
assurer la sécurité de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens évoqué des mesures simples
mais qu'il faut prendre il faut lutter
contre le contrôle au faciès et contre
les discrimination opérée par certaines
certaines certaine force une partie des
forces de l'ordre il faut en finir avec
un certain nombre d'armes de maintien de
l'ordre qui peuvent provoquer des dégâts
les flash ball le taser etc etc
il faut retrouver une peau lisse qui
soit apaisée de proximité au service des
citoyens et va devoir être désinscrites
d escalade de la violence dans les
relations avec la présence est à vous
pour le front national
je vous ai vu réagir aussi encore une
fois pour la gauche la faute bien encore
des policiers alors les policiers il ya
encore quelques jours à trappes sont des
cas et c'est juste pour enlever une
épave de voiture
je suis désolé il ya évidemment de
soutien matériel à apporter et c'est là
où a failli la droite clairement en
sabrant dans les effectifs mais aussi un
soutien moral à apporter à cette police
parce que quand il n'y a pas de volonté
politique derrière quand monsieur le
chef d'état lui-même se bat au chevet de
monsieur de théo qu'elle est même plus
le nom d'ailleurs cette ville nikon de
théo a sans même savoir s'il avait été
s'il était totalement innocente cette
affaire là je suis désolé c'est que les
policiers savaient partie des
professions qui suicide le plus c'est
des gens qui sont ne sont pas du tout
soutenu politiquement donc oui il faut
les renforcer matériellement il faut les
renforcer moralement
et oui on demande une présomption de
légitime défense quand interviennent
voilà on demande aussi évidemment alors
là où je vous rejoins il faut pas non
plus pour ce qui est du renseignement
pas non plus flics et l'ensemble de la
population alors qu'on est incapable de
suivre déjà les les fils et s très
concrètement expulsé aussi les étrangers
fils et s les les gens soupçonnaient
aussi de connivence avec l'ennemi avec
des gens qui veulent nous tuer très
clairement le but du jeu est quand même
le dégager du temps à ses policiers dans
les conditions de travail sont juste
déplorable
jean michel fourgous est à vous pour
parler de sécurité alors vous avez été
interpellé à plusieurs reprises si vous
souhaitez prendre un moment pour
répondre ou si vous souhaitez embrayé
sur vos propositions non seulement sur
les effectifs depuis je vous rappelle
que la mesure la plus destructrice du
nombre de policiers
1 c'est vous la connaissez il ya environ
cinq cent mille personnes qui exercent
le
métier de sécurité il ya 140 mille
policiers nationaux 98 fred cent mille
gendarmes près de trente mille policiers
municipaux plus 100 millions 250 mille
agents de sécurité plus ou moins privé
limité très différent ça fait environ
500000 la mesure la plus destructrice
d'aidé de ses effectifs c'est les 35
heures sans lever 10 % de 518 6 mois
termine à la laissez moi vous parler
effectivement les charges est
intéressant mais parlez pas de vérité
c'est 10% rejeté ces 10 % ces cinq cent
mille cinquante mille alors quand vous
reprocher à monsieur sarkozy pas quoi de
dix mille dix mille ans - bon voilà
c'est super et sur 50 mx et deuxièmement
les propositions c'est dix mille
policiers
d'ailleurs tout le monde à peu près
semble d'accord sur dix mille policiers
supplémentaires tant mieux quand on est
d'accord sur quelques jeux puis
deuxièmement les places de prison les
propositions surtout seize mille places
de prison et c'est raisonnable je pense
que c'est madame de bien à l'heure de
votre gouvernement que vous avez soutenu
vous notamment vous là qui avait arrêté
la construction des peines de prison qui
aujourd'hui manque cruellement et qui
met les gens et on a raison d'évoquer
les conditions dans les prisons qui sont
dramatiques pourquoi parce que madame
taubira enlevés
le pen a enlevé les places de plomb que
les bras mais bon tout ça nos éminents
cela dit la coordination et vous descend
à moins de se parler c'est très
important il faut garder une l'ensemble
des chances de récolter il faut
corneilhan semble aussi des acteurs ce
qui a plein de gens aujourd'hui qui joue
un rôle sur la sécurité
donc voilà il faut des moyens modernes
il faut donc c'est le projet bien sûr
que nous on présente c'est d'améliorer
la pertinence la de diminuer la rapidité
d'intervention des policiers ou des
services d'urgence aussi d'une seule
général aurait donc c'est un beau projet
pour l'ensemble et de de cette
circonscription est de cette
agglomération et on s'arrête là on va
voir les temps paroles qui vont
s'afficher dans un instant juste le
temps de lancer la deuxième thématique
c'est la question de l'éducation c'est
un des dossiers prioritaires aussi de ce
nouveau gouvernement sous cette
présidence est emmanuel macron avec
entre autres un retour par exemple à la
semaine de quatre jours chacune des
communes pourra ensuite choisir on va
venir dans un instant qu'on va voir les
temps de parole de chacun et de chacune
qui s afficher et on le voit matip de
andrew et vous avez un petit peu plus de
retard que silvia quandt
et comme s'il y a quand à lui pardon et
sandrine grand bang en revanche jean
michel faure vous avez pris un peu plus
d'avancé ainsi comme luc miserait on va
donc commencer avec vous sandrine grands
groupes pardon sur les questions
d'éducation aujourd'hui lorsque vous
entendez ce nouveau gouvernement évoquer
notamment à un retour à l'ancienne
formule des rythmes scolaires qui
avaient été portées par le candidat
goûts que vous représentez ici benoît
hamon vous vous dites toi qu'on combat
détricoter un petit peu ce qui avait été
fait vous dites c'est un dossier
prioritaire moi j'ai pas du tout
l'impression dans ce que je vois que
c'est un dossier prioritaire pour le
nouveau chef de l'état
il n'y a pas de moyens supplémentaires
c'est un moyen constant alors qu'il
annonce quelques mesures qui signifie
clairement qui va enlever un certain
sens doit donc sur sur les rythmes
scolaires
tu crois qu'il faut abandonner être
sérieux ont tous ceux qui s'intéressent
vraiment au bien-être de l'enfant et de
et qui s'intéresse à tout ce qui est
pédagogie éducation savent qu'on ne peut
pas améliorer les choses quand on met le
maximum d'heures sur le minimum de temps
donc il faut du temps pour
l'apprentissage la semaine de quatre
jours et demi elle est reconnue comme
étant efficace et revenir à 4 jours ce
sera quelque chose qui serait vraiment
dommageable pour les apprentissages
donc après la question c'est comment on
met en place et comment les communes
accompagne comment l'état accompagne
financièrement ces sept mais on a vécu
avec quatre jours et demi pendant très
très longtemps la droite las vegas et on
venu à quatre jours depuis depuis
malaisie jean-michel s'il vous plaît
donc voila moi je pense réellement que
quatre jours et demi ou quatre jours et
demi
c'est absolument indispensable mais que
derrière il faut que l'accompagnement
soit un accompagnement là encore humain
des moyens humains ça veut dire des
recrutements ça veut dire de l'argent
supplémentaire pour l'éducation
nationale parce que c'est bien de mettre
la haute technologie mais en monnaie il
faut que y est simplement de
l'encadrement et des projets il ya un
certain nombre de communes
j'ai pas hésité parce que quand on voit
ça va de nouveau créé les foudres de
deux mondes ensuite il se trouve qu'il
ya un certain nombre de villes qui n'ont
pas de projet en fait pour la jeunesse
et donc c'est pour ça aussi il faut
compenser sert à la fois les
accompagnements donc des quatre jours et
demi par les communes et en même temps
des projets pour la jeunesse que vous
avez tous les uns les autres beaucoup de
questions à poser à jean michel fourgous
qui pourra répondre mais après il risque
d'avoir un petit décalage de toutes
parts si c'était juste préciser la
chaudière j'ai bien comment vous pas et
de passer votre temps on nous dit à dire
que oui de 90 ans la maison la grèce
mais je la réalité c'est que ce point
s'il est pas fan mais je ne suis pas
permis de préciser que vous agrée
sillage ce sera sur le plateau je
prêterai juste c'est évidemment de la
même manière que si vous étiez
excusez-moi de la même manière que si
vous étiez interpellé s'il vous plaît la
même manière que si vous étiez
interpellé faudrait aussi que vous
preniez du temps pour pouvoir répondre
c'est juste justement ce qui s'appelle
de de l'équité une égalité de traitement
entre les uns et les autres et je n'ai
jamais mentionné qu'une personne plus
que notre été agressé sur ce plateau
voilà c'est à vous à présent pour le
front national et quelles sont vos
propositions en matière d'éducation le
regard que vous portez sur les premières
mesures annoncées
les premières mesures annoncées a priori
c'est une liberté sur
les rythmes scolaires est a priori je
pense qu'on va encore dans cette logique
de concurrence qui va forcément
s'instaurer dire que c'est assez amusant
de la gauche qui parle tout le temps
d'égalité en fait n'a juste renforcer
l'inégalité entre les communes entre
celles qui avaient de l'argent et moyens
d'avoir des vrais temps périscolaire et
ceux qui n'en avaient pas les moyens et
donc je pense que le gros souci de notre
jeunesse c'est justement de re maîtriser
tous ses fondamentaux
est-ce qu'on va pas se mentir quand on
maîtrise la langue de victor hugo ça
sort bien dans la vie que quand on
maîtrise le faux de cortex est vraiment
c'est important revenir sur
l'orthographe le français revenir sur
les fondamentaux et éviter la en fait la
vraie histoire des restes des rythmes
scolaires
on peut en discuter oui à priori
normalement les enfants préfèrent avoir
une coupure qui sont petits sont jeunes
ils ont besoin d'une coupure milieu de
la semaine
soit mais c'est j'ai presque envie de
vous dire c'est presque annexes ce qu'il
faut c'est vraiment quel est le contenu
qu'on leur met à l'intérieur et il est
temps que l'idéologie or sortent de
l'école pour revenir en fait sur de
l'instruction on a trop parlé peut-être
d'éducation revenons à l'instruction les
mathématiques le français les langues
revenir chaque 15 bilan que ça c'est
intéressant et la logique du macron
c'est une espèce de progressivement de
privatisation un système à l'anglo
saxonne où est là je crains qu'avec sa
25 ans ressemble aux jeunes britanniques
qui sont surendettés avant même de
rentrer dans la vie professionnelle
c'est bien quand hadopi réécoutez voilà
pour moi l'éducation nationale c'est
plus une vieille poupée qui maintenant
c'est complètement déchiqueté il
faudrait peut-être revenir purement et
simplement à l'instruction publique et
civiques
ce qui donne dans l'instruction
apprendre les fondamentaux alors la
langue française bien évidemment bien
maîtriser l'écriture bien aimé maîtriser
le calcul et la langue française parce
que notre outil de communication à tous
français quelle que soit notre niveau
d'instruction c'est par la langue c'est
par le langage ou écrit ou parlé mais si
on n'a pas ce langage c'est comme la clé
de la communication c'est extrêmement
important donc réapprendre les
fondamentaux la langue française pour le
coup c'est important parce que c'est
parce a fait rayonner notre culture
n'oublions pas le rayonnement de la
france à la francophonie donc la langue
française est quelque chose d
extrêmement important qu'on devrait
mieux
maîtriser et puis ensuite l'échec
scolaire de nos gamins qui sortent à la
plus de 150000 qui sortent par an sans
diplôme manque de qualification
forcément c'est du chômage chômage les
l'intense je vous fais pas le schéma
habituel on s'y fait et c'est quand même
moi ça me fait envie de crier ce genre
de choses car on le sait mais il n'y a
pas grand chose qui change de la même
façon qu'il ya des gamins arrivent en
sixième qui savent pas forcément bien
lire et non pas une vraie compréhension
de leurs textes
oui mais ça c'est la base après comment
voulez vous continuer à faire des choses
si à la base les enfants arrivent pas
avoir l'air aqi les fondamentaux c'est
fondamental le cmi dresser tavaux pour
le parti communiste
oui alors ce serait bien que vous
évitiez de caricaturer quand vous dites
la gauche 1
il ya différentes sensibilités à gauche
comme il ya différentes sensibilités à
droite où on connaît votre laïus lire
écrire compter
très bien la réalité c'est qu'on a
besoin de quelque chose de beau oui
c'est essentiel mais il ya bien d'autres
choses pires et l'éducation nationale
justement elle est importante pour cela
ce gouvernement qui a mis en place des
rythmes scolaires les rythmes scolaires
c'est une bonne chose on a eu des débats
sur traque moi j'étais pas d'accord avec
la manière dont ça s'est passé parce
qu'il y avait pas assez de concertation
contrairement à ce qui est dit et c'est
la réalité c'est fondamentalement c'est
une bonne mesure
sauf qu'elle a été très mal appliquée
moi je reprochais qu'on n'ait pas eu de
débat quand on dit liberté c'est du
grand n'importe quoi
la réalité c'est que oui on a besoin de
quatre jours et demi mais pas en
laissant la liberté
tous les gens sérieux savent que la demi
journée c'est samedi matin et c'est pas
le mercredi matin
si c'est l'intérêt de l'enfant qui est
pointée c'est le samedi matin et en plus
c'est l'intérêt des parents parce que
c'est le seul moment où la plupart des
parents peuvent voir les enseignants
donc ça c'est c'est une première chose
quant à ce gouvernement
on a un affichage douze élèves alors
tout de suite on this avec une priorité
c'est pas une priorité du tout ça c'est
de la vitrine c'est fait n'importe
comment
quand on pense que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale était une cheville
ouvrière de monsieur sarkozy
on a tous compris sur comment ça va se
passer ensuite au niveau des des
contenus de 2
quand on fait appel à pôle emploi pour
recruter en terme de pédagogie en terme
de psycho pédagogie et bien on s'attend
à des jours qu'ils soient meilleurs
il ya beaucoup d'écart et qui commence à
se creuser entre les uns et les autres
donc on va essayer de resserrer un tout
petit peu et d'équilibré ça sur le
prochaine thématique et sur votre carte
blanche aux uns et aux autres
c'est à vous mature à lévis françois
soumises alors d'abord merci d'avoir
inscrit cette thématique là pour le coup
dans le débat parce que je crois que la
question de l'école est une question qui
est centrale dans notre société
moi je travaille sur un établissement
scolaire je suis sait plus sur un lycée
dans les yvelines donc je vis cette
question là au quotidien
je crois que l'école c'est beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus que d'apprendre à compter
à lire et à écrire c'est ça mais c'est
beaucoup plus large que ça et
heureusement parce que c'est un endroit
où on apprend à vivre ensemble à
discuter et quand on discute on apprend
à parler français c'est un endroit où on
cultive
on apprend dans la musique c'est quelque
chose beaucoup plus large que ça et
c'est ce modèle là qu'il faut préserver
en défendant une école publique laïque
et gratuite
et j'insiste sur ces trois éléments et
notamment sur la question de la gratuité
parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui que
l'enseignement a un coût pour les
familles dans ce pays que ce soit la
cantine
que ce soit les les activités extra
scolaires qui sont le fruit des la
réforme des rythmes scolaires que ce
soit les transports que ce soit le
matériel etc
ça a un coût et donc il faut une école
qui soit réellement gratuite ensuite il
faut revaloriser et renforcer le métier
des enseignants parce que ce n'est pas
vrai que cette question-là a été traitée
est pris en compte par le gouvernement
et le quinquennat qui vient de s'écouler
on a aujourd'hui plus d'élèves par
classe qu'au début du quinquennat et
donc il faut recruter massivement des
enseignants il faut revoir la formation
des enseignants
parce qu'effectivement je rejoins luc
miserait sur cette question-là être
enseignant transmettre des connaissances
dans savoir ça ne s'apprend pas ce n'est
pas comme ça ça ça s'apprend pardon et
donc il faut pouvoir le développer
et puis il faut garantir les conditions
d'une école qui soit réellement
inclusive sur la question du handicap
par exemple il faut titulariser les avs
qui sont les assistantes de vie scolaire
qui permettent aux élèves handicapés de
pouvoir être scolarisés comme l'ensemble
des enfants de ce pays dont vous voyez
que la mission de l'école elle est
beaucoup plus large
c'est une immense ambition pour notre
pays et c'est une immense richesse et
donc il faut investir massivement
sur cette question là parce que quand on
forme une génération eh bien on forme
l'avenir du pays avant de vous faire
réagir jean michel fourgous puisque vous
êtes encore exprimé sur cette thématique
là mathilde andraud sylvia cantaluppi si
vous souhaitez prendre le temps vous
avez encore plus d'une minute d'écart
avec les autres candidats qu'ils soient
exprimés vous pouvez réagir bien
évidemment sur la question d'éducation
sur ce qui a été dit je n'en revenais à
ça c'est qu'il y ait des fondamentaux et
que c'est pas une question de nom mais
d'attentes et de partage du temps
scolaire parce que il ya apprendre à
vivre ensemble bien évidemment mais je
pense que fondamentalement vous avez
vous l'avez l'air de dire que c'est pas
le reste ne peut pas être à qui sait les
fondamentaux sont pas acquis comment
voulez-vous à apprendre à vous servir
d'un de quel que ce soit un ordinateur
ou quoi que ce soit si vous n'avez pas
parce qu'on peut vous apprendre même si
vous ne savez pas lire si on vous on
emploie des mots vous comprenez pas s'il
ya pas une bonbonne font pression ça ne
marche pas donc je persiste à dire que
tant qu'on n'aura pas donné une garantie
d'acquis des fondamentaux tout le reste
n'est que bavardage sur cette question
là il pour éviter effectivement que les
inégalités se creusent dans sur cette
question là il faut garantir un soutien
scolaire aux élèves les plus en
difficulté c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
parce que je veux dire c'est quelque
chose qui coûte cher et donc réservé à
des familles qui ont l'argent donc il
faut garantir par le service publication
de soutien scolaire aux élèves les plus
en difficulté et d'ailleurs pour ça je
pense que là ça peut ça vient pas
forcément à un coût pour le ministère de
l'instruction publique comme je le dis
c'est que ça peut être très bien remis
en sous forme d'association il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont esseulés qui
peuvent participer à la vie de la
société en apportant un soutien scolaire
et donc la lia humain qui ses clients la
pédagogie pour la pédagogie je pense que
les enfants ils sont parés à l'école
toute la journée
non
nous avons le soutien oui je pense qu'on
peut très bien le faire par milieu
associatif bien évidemment je me suis
dit c'est bon la pédagogie avant oui
bien sûr attendre ou et si vous
souhaitez des romans sur l'éducation
semble également vous pouvez si vous le
souhaitez rester quelques pas avoir une
école à plusieurs vitesses ça c'est ça
doit rester un service public qui est
garantie pour tous les enfants
et effectivement le grand enjeu
aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que et
benoît hamon avait réussi à obtenir que
la promesse de françois hollande sur les
60000 postes soit maintenu et qu'on a
réussi ce n'était pas suffisant je suis
bien d'accord parce qu'on avait un
nombre d'élèves qui arrivaient une
classe d'âge qui arrivait qui faisait
que même avec ces recrutements c'est pas
assez et on a au moins au moins réussi
ça a recruté les hausses avaient au
moins soixante mille enseignants
supplémentaires qui ont été recrutés et
maintenant il faut absolument que après
avoir mis le paquet sur le premier cycle
le deuxième cycle soit vraiment étudié
avec beaucoup d'attention collèges et
lycées jean michel fourgous est à vous
vivez comme comme lit des choses comme
ça enfin c'est comme tout ce qui est
raconté sur les résultats de monsieur
mandat circonscription aucun maire ne le
soutiens pour ça parce que vous montez
délibérément les maires ne supporte pas
ça pouvait le gaver que que soient de
gauche ou droite mais pas mentir d ibm
mon seul et 10 sur le rythme scolaire
bon pour une fois j'ai des corps avec la
gauche bon c'est vrai qu'il faut deux
coupures il faut une coupure le dimanche
c'est ça la théorie puisque la structure
en psychologie jeu jusque là le sujet et
chez un ancien chercheur et des
questionnements c'est de copieux une le
jeu une le mercredi et une le dimanche
effectivement donc on peut très bien
s'amuser mais cela dit bon deuxième
ordre
c'est moins d'heures de cours par jour
on augmenter le nombre de
le nom le nombre d'heures de cours dont
les enfants sont plus fatigués salle
touche à la concentration
cette réforme est une calamité c'est une
c'est une justement parce que ça fait
baisser la concentration donc on va
décrocher un peu plus sa pizza c'est
tout donc il faut il faut faire bouger
cet été je me balade chez vous le savez
deuxièmement le problème mais je crois
que c'était 10 et la pédagogie
la pédagogie est les trouve contraint de
trois magistrats les enfants s'ennuient
moi je les ai vécu ça a été le combat de
ma vie d'ailleurs je parle j'ai arrêté
mes études à 16 ans parce que je
m'ennuie à l'école bon donc aujourd'hui
grâce à la révolution à l'innovation
numérique vous êtes des supports
beaucoup plus interactive vous avez bien
sûr ils peuvent apprendre dans dans dans
l'école et en dehors des murs de l'école
et il faut développer le plaisir
d'apprendre le besoin d'apprendre tout
seul l'autonomie et c'est ce qui se
passe donc aujourd'hui on draine
révolutionner bien sûr la pédagogie donc
l'école les profs prennent plus de
plaisir à enseigner les élèves prennent
plus de plaisir à prendre c'est ça
l'objectif donc il faut se battre là
dessus le monde entier où je vais aux
états unis en chine en russie
voilà c'est la solution plutôt que de se
battre sur le problème de certains
périmètres
aujourd'hui c'est le fond c'est cette
forme du contenu sur lesquels nous
devons nous battre ce qui s'appelle la
pédagogie voilà et puis et puis vous
dire que heil en cours on est considéré
comme un modèle
moi je me présente pourquoi pas ce que
j'ai réussi ce serait bien que les gens
qui veulent un député un immense qu'ils
ont réussi
moi je vais vous éprouvez j'ai déposé ce
projet réussi des choses elle encore que
d'autres communes viennent voir d'autres
pays ce qui serait bien c'est qu'on est
bien sûr des députés qui peuvent dire
moi j'ai réussi je voudrais mettre ça au
niveau national je pense que ce serait
pas incohérent je vous arrête
si vous souhaitez réagir encore sur la
question de l'éducation sinon nous
allons passer en amour si j'ai bien
compris vous revenez pas à la semaine de
quatre jours
l'année prochaine et ensuite moi ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que là où ce
gouvernement qui vient de se terminer a
échoué c'est que quand on veut les
quitter on remet pas quand on change les
règles de
du jeu on ne remet pas sur les
collectivités territoriales
le coût de cette réforme c'est à c'était
à l'état d'assumer cela c'est peut-être
une réponse et il est à assumer en
partie passé mais en partie une réalité
non la réalité si tu devais aussi un
principe de réalité financier qui était
comment on fait pour à la fois refaire
le recrutement du personnel qui était
nécessaire et en même temps avoir les
moyens de pour eric m'a accompagné ces
réformes mal préparées les m on a baissé
de 1 match sans les moyens des
collectivités vous êtes au courant et
n'ont donc s'arrêter sur ce sujet si
vous souhaitez répondre et on s'arrête
après le fait qu'on ait connu pareille
sur ce sujet si vous souhaitez répondre
oui j'aime plutôt que de jouer sur des
femmes qui font d'une manière correcte
mais voilà ça c'est toujours des jeux de
manipulation là vous répondez jamais aux
questions jean michel faure ou s'il vous
plaît laissez juge du 20 % de nos moyens
dans les communes c'est de ramener ses
tacles et c'est peut-être sa réponse en
gang alors voilà je suis pas allé quand
il ya une obligation qui vous a été
posée que vous
alors on va s'arrêter là sur cette
thématique de l'éducation signé les uns
et les autres souhaitent suivre les
règles du jeu et mes coups s'est jusqu'à
présent il me semble que c'est moi qui
distribue les cartes donc si je vous
souhaitez répondre à l'essai une
question est une question qui a été
posée sur sql en cours revient à 4 jours
donc c'est le jeu des questions à priori
vous avez des questions les uns sont les
zombies qui se joue
toujours tous les to les saisons demande
qui a été fait les profs élèves
les acteurs sont partisans de revenir se
dit vous avez dit vous même le mercredi
et le dimanche bon d'accord comme
coupure donc il faut que mercredi bah
oui il faut que mercredi soit un jour de
congé sans les loisirs ils organiseront
un débat sur la question de la réforme
des rythmes scolaires vient dans les
prochains jours sans doute après la
campagne ce sera à suivre sur notre
antenne s'est d'ores et déjà prévu le
rendez vous est pris
on va voir autant de paroles s'afficher
juste vous avons au passé aussi à vos
cartes blanches aux uns et aux autres
vous aurez plus ou moins de temps pour
vous exprimer en fonction du retard que
vous avez pu prendre dans les temps de
parole si on peut voir ce temps des
chronomètres qui sa fille jean michel
faure vous avez le plus aidé avance
mathieu d'andrew et vous êtes très en
retard sur votre carte blanche quel est
le sujet que vous souhaitez mettre en
avant dans cette campagne celui qui vous
semble le plus important lorsque vous
vous présenter aux électeurs
je voulais parler à l'occasion de cette
carte blanche d'une exigence dans la vie
politique qui dépasse même ma simple
candidature je pense que désormais il
est impératif que tous politiques de
droite comme de gauche comme marcheurs
non marcheurs et en tête
l'unité nationale clairement nous
souffrons très fin très concrètement de
ce monde de cette visée la de ce combat
pour la france nous cette course ercis
transcription et tremblay matic à cet
égard elle est en piste et à las vegas
ou d'un véritable cancer celui du
communautarisme
une logique qui a été qui est d'empiler
les communautés les lézina côté des
autres de jouer dehors du coup sa vie si
la vie politique parce qu'on est dans
une logique de clientèle de concurrence
entre ces clientèles et on ne vise plus
cette unité nationale et très
concrètement le communautarisme a fait
le lit du développement de la violence
dans les quartiers à développer tous des
ghettos
voilà c'est que si reconstruction en
témoigne et je pense qu'il faut être
très ferme maintenant désormais sur
cette volonté d'unité nationale de faire
de l'école on en parle est un ascenseur
social mais aussi un facteur
d'assimilation pour lutter et lutter
aussi fermement sur nos principes
républicains liberté égalité fraternité
qu'ils sont totalement oubliés dans ces
quartiers là où la liberté de la femme
recul et je pense que c'est un très bon
curseur et l'argent veut là je vous le
dit énormément à la gauche quand elles
balayent du revers de la main le cadre
des cafés de sevran où le cadet quartier
de la chapelle
vraiment il est nécessaire au nom de la
fraternité là aussi qui est sur le
fronton de nos mairies de ne pas laisser
des français emprisonnés dans ces
ghettos
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
d'aller vivre ailleurs et de dans ces
endroits où la loi républicaine passe
après les principes religieux les
préceptes religieux fanatique
parce que le bout du bout de cette
logique communautaire c'est quoi ces les
attentats convient aujourd'hui mais il
ya tout avant d'arriver au bout de cette
logique aussi tout ce quotidien tous ces
atermoiements tous ces négociations sur
nos libertés et nos libertés
individuelles et liberté vestimentaire
la liberté d'entreprendre même et il
n'est pas question que la république
reculé pour ça j'en appelle à la
conscience politique à la morale
politique de tous les candidats
nous sommes très attachés au principe de
laïcité nous sommes très attachés au
principe de la primauté de la france et
de la loi française avant tout je
souhaite que ça soit un principe qui
irradie l'ensemble de la politique
française
je mets cette question la passat et je
crois qu'il ya un vrai clivage attention
la liste elle s'applique à tout le monde
on n'utilise pas comme une arme contre
une religion contre une croyance contre
une partie de la population vers lui
alors que par exemple les biens de ces
nations qui gangrènent position et
pouvait prend position contre le
concordat en alsace lorraine qui
garantit un certain nombre de droits à
une communauté
siens ont propositions c'est notre les
crèches dans les séries parce que là on
a décidé vous a entendu aussi tout le
monde regardait du sens pour des
exploits mais après sur la carte blanche
allez-y oui mais sobre sauf que pour moi
cette comparaison est complètement
vicieuse et vicié on n'a aucun alsacien
qui impose à l'ensemble de la population
française aux femmes alsacienne de se
balader avec des quoi parce que je vous
ai dit je disais c'est pour tous
oui sauf que leurs concurrentes je vous
parle du recul de la loi de la française
je pense pas qu'on a les actions ne
respecte pas su prétexte d'être alsacien
la loi française alors que concrètement
dans nos quartiers on ne respecte pas
cette loi qui sans me suivez nous et
bien sûr tv fil 78 nous parlons de la
11e circonscription des yvelines et non
pas de ce qui se passe en alsace si bien
qu'on est avec lui c'est à vous dégoûter
moi ma carte blanche je voulais la
dédier à une femme que j'ai rencontrée
lors du début de la campagne de nicolas
dupont aignan qui en fait la fondatrice
de la brigade des mers
cette femme mange la connaissais pas est
ce elle nous a raconté son travail
d'où ça venait voilà quand elle dit aux
femmes et à toutes les femmes parce que
malheureusement il n'y a pas que les
femmes des ghettos qui ont ce genre de
problème de boulet maire réveillez vous
c'est à dire qu'il faut effectivement
donner des chances à vos enfants quand
el himma francs avant la lal angoisses
de toutes les mères dans ces fameux
quatre quartiers ghettos c'était que les
enfants deviennent des délinquants a dit
maintenant on n'en est plus là on a peur
du bien de terroristes donc il ya un
vrai problème
on a construit il ya des années des
ghettos on les a renforcés on les a
repeint de temps en temps on a mis trois
packs rete en est content les ghettos
sont de plus en plus des ghettos
tant qu'on ne serait pas sorti de ce
piège infernal on n'y arrivera pas donc
il ya un moment il va falloir donner aux
maires et aux familles parce qu'en fait
le secret de fonctionnement de la
société
c'est avant toute chose la famille à
condition que les familles et les
conditions correctes pour pouvoir
fonctionner des logements corinthe et
des écoles correct mais la première
instruction qu au delà des enfants elle
est dans le milieu familial
il va falloir à un moment que les maires
qui sont le coeur de la famille puisse
donner à leurs enfants l'éducation et
les instructions et les aspects de la
civilité
tout ça c'est le coeur de la famille
il ya un moment il va falloir donner le
sens de l'unité l'unité de la nation
elle est par une unité de traitement et
une équité
la liberté c'est très bien la qualité on
peut toujours en parler il faudrait de
temps en temps pensé à la fraternité
sans règle en fait tu avoues pour la
carte blanche ensuite ce sera lui qui
miserait puis à mathurin lévis vous
aurez un petit peu mon temps en matière
à lévis vous avez pris un peu d'avancé
ensuite on passera aux conclusions que
l'émission se poursuivra ensuite avec un
second plateau
oui c'est un sujet sur lequel benoît
hamon est intervenue depuis quelques
jours qui a été évoqué un petit peu par
mathurin libye au début de l'émission
qu'il la question de la réforme du droit
du travail qui est un qui se profile le
projet est encore assez floue m'enfin on
voit bien la direction qui est prise par
ce gouvernement et c'est dommage qu
effectivement il n'y a pas de
représentant de la république en marche
pour justement interpellé sur ce sujet
la tendance avait commencé le travail
sur don sur la réalité de ce qui se
profile on est sur la une
un abaissement des protections sociales
et on nous explique que grâce à cet
abaissement on va pouvoir créer de
l'emploi
quand on regarde ce qui s'est passé dans
les autres pays ça ne marche pas ce
qu'on a croisé la précarité c'est
notamment dans l'est tout à l'heure des
femmes et du rôle de la famille on a des
femmes qui sont dans des situations dans
la circonscription de plus en plus
précaires qui sont les premières
touchées justement par les situations de
grande pauvreté est donc là ce qu'on est
en train de préparer et sur lesquelles
il faut absolument alerter nos
concitoyens et l'enjeu c'est la
sélection de leur dire attention le vote
vote les déterminants par rapport à
cette question de casse de la protection
sociale qui est en marche
vous devez absolument réagir parce qu'on
est en train de devrais m'en mettre à
bas tout un système de protection
sociale qui était absolument essentiel
et qui faisait aussi la fierté du modèle
français donc on est là sur une logique
folle d'évolution sociale qui est
extrêmement alarmante
le problème majeur qui tient tous et
l'économie et le développement
économique et le développement de
l'économie réelle
or là on est parti sur une économie des
financiers
monsieur macron issus des banques
d'affaires leur spécialité c'est un de
regrouper pour licencier et de
participer à la fraude fiscale
pudiquement appelée évasion fiscale
voire optimisation fiscale
donc ce dont on a besoin c'est de
relancer l'économie et de relancer
l'économie
ça c'est possible parce qu'on a les
financements il ya la banque centrale
européenne a mis dans le circuit 1000
milliards d'euros ils sont passés où on
nous parle toujours il faut évaluer
quelle évaluation dans tout ça on n'a
rien du tout et ça c'est de l'emploi
donc nos quartiers il souffre de stade
de l'économie réelle c'est à dire de
tout ce qui peut être mis en place sur
par exemple la rénovation urbaine au
niveau de la rénovation thermique
notamment pour l'environnement de tout
ce qui peut toucher les transports de
tout ce qui n'est pas délocalisable
pourvu qu'on sous traitent pas à
l'entreprise machin qui sous traitent
elles mêmes à l'autre entreprise etc
et c'est donc en développant l'économie
réelle de proximité eh bien on résout
tout un tas de problèmes
naturally 7 à vous rapidement jean
beaulieu minutes effectivement ça serait
bien c'est que ce serait parfait ça ne
sera pas une carte blanche une carte
verte parce que je souhaite quand même
qu'on parle d'écologie dans le débat que
nous avons on en parle trop peu et c'est
une question absolument majeur et donc
le programme de jean luc mélenchon qui
s'intitule l avenir en commun faisait de
cette question là une priorité moi j'ai
la conviction qu'il faut absolument
protéger notre écosystème et pour
s'assortir des énergies qui polluent
notre planète sortir de l'énergie
nucléaire et je suis le seul qui ait
signé sur la circonscription l'appel du
réseau sortir du nucléaire
je crois que c'est une vitalité nous
avons besoin d'envisager de passer d'ici
quelques années 50 ans peut-être à 100%
d'énergies renouvelables nous avons
besoin de donner les moyens à notre
agriculture de faire la grande
transition biologique pour garantir une
alimentaire une alimentation saine à
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens de
révolutionner la façon dont on se
déplace dans ce pays moi je crois encore
que le rail et la façon le train est la
façon la plus écologique de se déplacer
donc il faut renforcer ce mode de
déplacement
alors là je crois que notre économie de
manière générale il faut qu'on apprenne
à produire autrement pour respecter à la
fois les sommes qu'ils produisent à la
fois l'envié
demant est à la fois les animaux qui
vivent sur notre planète il faut
absolument protéger cet écosystème et on
ne peut pas accepter que rien ne soit
fait pendant ce quinquennat en faveur de
l'environnement donc il faut des députés
issus de la france insoumise pour porter
ces questions là jean michel fourgous
c'est à vous 45 secondes ce sera bien
également
oui l'homme moi je voudrais rappeler que
la démocratie c'est important on va il y
un des représentants du peuple
donc il ya des règles suffisamment
surpris que madame et ne soit pas là je
suis surpris que la représentant deux
ans la candidate et dans ses
présentations elles ne connaissent pas
le nom
le nombre le nombre des communes de sa
circonscription elle pense qu'un à 647
quoi là pour voir l'ombre c'est vrai
mais elle est elle se trompe même sur
les crises soient là sur l'orthographe
d'une des villes de sa circonscription
qu'elle a derrière il ya bien deux et
derrière je jamais enfin il ya elle se
trompe sur le elle rencontre un maire
elle pense que c'est un autre mais elle
se trompe de l'eau fin demain on doit
avoir des représentants qui connaissent
les réseaux qui connaissent les dossiers
les grands enjeux qui connaissent les
communes à minimum
je trouve que cette dérive au niveau
national que il semblerait qu'à un tiers
en fait des candidats dans marche
non aucune
aucune racine aucune compétence
particulière ça m'inquiète un dernier
point je vois pas ce que vous avez dans
moi je me bats sur vous le savez sur
l'école c'est ma passion donc vous aurez
l'école la plus on a plus moyen
d'éducation talent et avec c'est
l'université qui fait paris saclay qui
doit rentrer dans le top 20 du
classement de shanghaï voilà donc ça on
a peu parlé d'éducation grec l'alba je
vous arrête parce que vous avez beaucoup
beaucoup trop d'avancé par rapport aux
autres ensuite on passa à vos
conclusions les temps forts ils vont
s'afficher pendant ce temps pour que
l'émission puisse puisse avancer et
laisser rentrer les autres candidats qui
eux aussi vont venir s'exprimer et qui
se présentent dans cette 11e
circonscription
on y va pour vos conclusions vous en
prie sylvia cantaluppi pour debout la
france si vous aviez un dernier mot aux
électeurs c'est maintenant écoutez moi
je pense qu'il faut donner à emmanuel
macron une opposition franche massive et
sincère parce que lie à un moment où
tous les patriotes de ce pays qu'ils
soient de tous bords peu importe on a
tous l'amour de notre culture et de
notre pays chevillée au corps on ne peut
pas laisser un gouvernement entre
guillemets d'amateurs faire tout et
n'importe quoi
je voudrais pour ma part pour mon pays
une assemblée nationale qui serait une
vraie assemblée de députés patriotes qui
défendent l'intérêt de leur pays qui ne
se contente pas comme c'est
malheureusement souvent le cas c'est une
chambre d'enregistrement des directives
européennes qu'elles viennent de
bruxelles ou d'ailleurs et j'en reviens
ce que je vous ai toujours la liberté
bien sûr l'égalité si on peut mais
surtout toujours et partout la
fraternité mathurin la vie oui moi je
suis le candidat qui représente le
programme de jean luc mélenchon l'avenir
en commun nous avons cette cohérence de
porter à la fois l'élection présentielle
et aux élections législatives le même
projet politique nous présentons 577
candidats et donc nous sommes prêts
demain à gouverner le pays et à
appliquer ce programme sur les bases que
j'ai décrite au cours de ce débat une
grande transformation de notre société
vers l'écologie faire plus de justice et
de solidarité et vers plus de démocratie
voilà quels sont les piliers les grandes
lignes de notre campagne et je
reviendrai sur la question du progrès
social qui me semble est déterminante et
moi je m'engage par exemple si je suis
vu députés à voter contre la réforme du
travail proposé par ayman emmanuel
macron et apporter plus tôt que cela une
augmentation des salaires est là
les réalisations des cdi pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse vivre mieux dans
notre pays qui m'attire d'andrew et la
très concrètement on est tous d'accord
sur le fait qu'on ne veut pas laisser
les pleins pouvoirs mais de macron c'est
vrai que c'est un peu faire se dirigent
si on en prend les sondages parce que
après l'euphorie de la présidentielle ou
du tout beau tout nouveau alors que
c'est quand même pas une personne issue
des équipes de hollande et qui fascine
plus pouvoir les républicains qui rêvent
de leurs alliés la vraie question est de
savoir qui est ce la vraie question est
de savoir qui est ce qui va faire
opposition et qui est ce qui va porter
la france au parlement parce que les
français aussi il faut que les français
reprennent le pouvoir dans ce pays là
est en effet qu'elle ne devienne la
chambre ne devienne pas une chambre
d'enregistrement comme on dit le
directeur européenne mais aussi de toute
cette clientèle qui entourent monsieur
macron et qui reste somme toute assez
obscur et refaire du neuf avec de
l'ancien parce qu'on a eu finalement vu
aucun renouveau je crois que les
français en ont assez il est nécessaire
qu'ils reviennent en force à l'assemblée
nationale avec miserait votre conclusion
le renouveau c'est plus de solidarité
plus de coopération et plus de
fraternité
là ce qu'on voit c'est la république des
affairistes donc c'est pas de cela qu'on
a besoin
jean luc mélenchon n'est pas
propriétaire de tout des idées
progressistes à gauche
nous avons nous même appelé à voter pour
lui donc ce qui est important c'est un
rassemblement ouvert s'appuyant
réellement sur les sur les valeurs de
gauche et c'est ça que je souhaite
défendre je disais tout à l'heure que
sur le projet de mâcon c'était une
catastrophe
il se trouve que ce projet c'est le
projet en fait de l'endroit temps qu'on
retrouve et d'ailleurs les grands
leaders de la droite aujourd'hui la
gaufre et on dit que
la conclusion j'aimerais juste que vous
laissiez les intégrer dans leur base
d'accord que ça veut dire qu'elle n'est
pas de gauche cette gauche-là donc donc
ses responsables à prendre ont dit
qu'ils étaient tout à fait d'accord avec
le projet de la pompe donc je vais me
faut absolument que l'on ait des voix de
gauche au parlement forte qu'ils se
fassent entendre
on a un député sortant qui à la fois
très ancré sur le territoire et qui a
fait beaucoup sur ces territoires pour
débloquer des dossiers
voici en national dit il est intervenu
pour réussir
donc on a des interventions qui ont
permis de débloquer sur la
circonscription des dossiers puis on a
aussi quelqu'un qui est un élu de
proximité mais qui est capable de se
faire entendre au niveau national et qui
est libre qui ne se croit pas au dessus
des lois lui qui respectent la loi et
qui pense aussi que quand il faut dire
non il le fait il est capable de le
faire et il l'a montré à la fois en
quittant le gouvernement et en disant
non aux lobbys quand il fallait faire
jean michel fourgous et à votre
conclusion
si oui alors bref simplement 90 % des
candidats investis par monsieur macron
sont de gauche donc je crois qu'il faut
en dire ça comme au niveau des droits de
gauche bon mais c'est du bon
deuxièmement si vous ne savez pas vous
venez de la prendre c'est bien
deuxièmement bien sûr que ces
démocraties en voie de gauche il faut la
protéger
je veux du souffle et il faut la
protéger ou les compris la laïcité
attention on en a parlé très rapidement
mais est un principe dans la
constitution quand vous et député coup
de faire respecter s'appelle l'égalité
homme femme je crois que sans le
préambule de la constitution
là on atteint un niveau et c'est vrai
que c'est vrai dans certaines villes
précitées on ne peut pas continuer à
tolérer ça on peut pas cette vision de
la femme moi je ne l'acceptent pas
certains ici l'acceptent visiblement ce
n'est pas mon cas et comptait sur moi en
tout cas pour le dire haut et fort et
faire les prendre les mesures qui
s'imposent bien sûr c'est la fin de
cette première séquence consacrée au
débat de la 11e circonscription dans les
yvelines on voit les les temps de parole
dans un instant ce sont cinq nouveaux
candidats qui vont nous rejoindre je le
rappelle tous n'ont pas souhaité non pas
pu
eux aussi s'exprimer c'est le cas de la
république en marche qui étaient aussi
conviés et qui n'a pas pu venir en
notant qu pape n'a pas voulu qui n'a pu
venir remplacer les explications qui
nous ont été données est libre à chacun
de les interpréter et à vous interpeller
les candidats sur plateau cinq autres
candidats vont venir nous rejoindre
juste après ce reportage qui revient sur
les enjeux de la circonscription merci à
vous si ce trappe et long cours la
verrière ou encore le mesnil saint denis
et saint cyr l'école la 11e
circonscription des yvelines ne recense
plus de 115 mille habitants une
population hétérogène qui en juin 2012
portée benoît hamon au poste de député
avec plus de 55% face au sortant
jean-michel fourgous maire d'elancourt
cinq ans plus tard le socialiste aura
occupé deux postes de ministres et
défendu les couleurs de son parti à la
présidentielle
son score à fragiliser sa position
puisque dans la commune de trappes où il
aura siégé quelques temps en tant que
conseiller municipal jean luc mélenchon
et la france insoumise réalisé à ce
scrutin un meilleur résultat face à un
benoît hamon affaibli jean michel
fourgous vice-président de saint-quentin
entend retrouver un poste qu'il occupait
de 1993 à 2002 seulement lui aussi doit
faire face à une difficulté
l'échec de françois fillon lors de la
présidentielle le candidat des
républicains s'est placée 3e dans sa
propre commune derrière notamment
emmanuel macron pour ces législatives ce
dernier est représenté par une candidate
de la société civile nadia qui espère
profiter d'une vague en marche au niveau
national au total treize candidats se
présentent dans la 11e circonscription
la gauche elle part divisée avec elle
les candidatures supplémentaires du
parti communiste de lutte ouvrière ou
encore du npa
de son côté le front national et et sa
conseillère régionale mathilde andraud
et doit faire face à la candidature du
front libéré à partie formée après
l'exclusion de militants favorables à
jean marie le pen principaux enjeux dans
cette circonscription l'éducation et
l'avenir entre autres des rythmes
scolaires défenseurs de la mesure benoît
hamon fait face à jean-michel fourgous
qui entend revenir une semaine de quatre
jours en profitant de la volonté d'
emmanuel macron de laisser plus de
liberté aux communes
la sécurité est aussi au coeur du
scrutin plusieurs faits divers ont
écorné l'image de ce secteur
60 à 80 je n'aurais qui tetra pour la
syrie ces derniers mois
le débat du premier tour dans cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines se poursuit
ce sont à présent cinq nouveaux
candidats qui nous ont rejoint mathieu
ruf est candidat pour le nouveau souffle
est en plateau bonsoir à vous et
christine et gaz bonsoir quand les
atteint lutte ouvrière mais dit emna war
bonsoir
bonjour vous êtes candidat divers c'est
ainsi que la préfecture vous à
cataloguer pour cette élection face
avoue vincent fournier bonsoir vous du
npa et yassine hamam bonsoir vous êtes
un candidat divers également dans cette
11e circonscription c'est comme ça que
la préfecture vous vous présente la
règle est la même le temps de parole
sera chronométrée bien sûr vous pouvez
échanger les uns avec les autres
premiers à tour de table et cette
question simple pourquoi les électeurs
doivent vous faire confiance et vous
accorder leur voix à dimanche au jeu
mais déjà parce que j'ai 23 ans et je
pense qu'il est important aujourd'hui
que la jeunesse se mobilise une jeunesse
d'autant plus issus des classes
populaires qui à mon avis est beaucoup
médiatisé mais se représenter
politiquement on parle beaucoup de nous
on nous donne très peu la parole et
souvent même si on est demi au devant de
la scène surtout à trappes on parle de
nous en des termes qui ne sont pas
toujours correct et il était important
aussi de montrer cette image là d'une
jeunesse qui se mobilisent en dehors de
tout clivage avec eux vraiment une
volonté de pragmatisme est vraiment de
casser toute cette logique partisane
traditionnel déjà séculaire en france
qui à mon avis n'est pas n'est pas
positif pour une évolution du pays dans
le sens où aujourd'hui
qui mieux que la jeunesse pour parler de
la france de demain j'ai envie de dire
pour lutte ouvrière
pourquoi les électeurs doit vous faire
confiance oui et bien pour défendre un
programme de lutte dans cette élection
553 candidats vont défendre le même
programme que nathalie arthaud a défendu
aux élections présidentielles un
problème un programme
préconisant la défense du camp des
travailleurs
1 l'interdiction des licenciements la
répartition du travail entre tous des
augmentations de salaire et
l'application de l'échelle mobile des
salaires et des retraites pour faire
face à toutes les attaques du patronat
et au chômage et au licenciement est
également et surtout pour parvenir à
cela le contrôle des comptes des
entreprises
dans cette société les travailleurs
produisent toutes les richesses
ils doivent être à même de contrôler les
comptes et ainsi de prévenir des
licenciements pour faits de boursiers
par exemple madame bonjour à tout le
monde
donc moi je rejoins
en collègue qui vient de s'exprimer en
premier c'est à dire que moi aussi je
n'en peux plus de
quand on exclut sa chance nouvelle
génération quand nous diabolise dans
tous les sens alors par rapport à mon
collègue j'ai plusieurs années de plus
ses 40 ans
dans plus d'expérience plus de vécu et
j'ai été on va dire un peu poussé auto
pousser un personne ne m'a poussé à
m'inscrire aux législatives est engagée
politiquement suite ou désastreuses
élections présidentielles qui viennent
d'avoir lieu où on nous a comme
d'habitude sucre et l'élection
on nous a fait croire qu'on avait une
multiplicité de choix mais au final on
n'avait aucun choix il y avait un monde
ancien
gauchiste
à droite centre enfin vous l'appelez
comme vous voulez mais ils sont tous
ensemble il y en a certains qui les
appelle oligarchie chez monsieur assauts
dino et monsieur mélenchon moi je les
appelle système et de l'autre côté on
avait le monde
extrême droite qui est diabolisé depuis
tous les temps donc en gros le logiciel
sait si vous voulez pas que les nazis
sortent de leur cachette et qu' ils
affrète des trains pour nos des portes
est ou sebha voter pour les anciens
malgré qu'ils ont un désastreux bilan
malgré qu'ils ont volé est riche et fait
de la prise en régie briller pour
laisser le garder du temps de parole
pour après donc bon ben je vais laisser
mon collector on va laisser les autres
candidats s'exprimer ensuite sur à
différentes thématiques où chacun pourra
bien évidemment à nouveau prendre la
parole au cours de cette demi heure
d'émission qui va qui va suivre sur
cette 11e circonscription vincent
fournier c'est à vous donc candidat npa
pourquoi les électeurs doivent vous
accorder la vivre à écouter comme l'a
dit philippe poutou lors du grand débat
des élections présidentielles les
candidats du npa vivent le même
quotidien que des millions de
travailleurs
moi par exemple je suis facteur jusqu'à
2400 euros par mois à peu près avec deux
enfants et je peux vous dire que les
fins de mois difficile que connaissent
des millions de français je sais ce que
c'est aussi et ça pour nous c'est plus
supportable alors que les richesses
abondent dans ce pays il ya de plus en
plus de milliardaires
il ya des richesse indécente un des
fortunes colossales
liliane bettencourt qui a 40 milliards
de fortune c'est pas possible
et pourtant c'est nous qui faisons
tourner la société et qu'on ramasse les
poubelles qu'on construise des voitures
qu'on distribue le courrier tous les
jours il n'y a rien qui tourne sans vous
et c'est ce qu'on a envie de dire dans
ces élections et donc en fait il faut
prendre conscience pour nous que on a le
pouvoir
les travailleurs qu'on peut faire tomber
le système capitaliste en s'organisant
en se rassemblant et bien sûr on
n'évitera pas une grève générale
nécessaires pour contraindre le grand
patronat
mais il faudra pour nous aller plus loin
qu'un mai 68 ou un joint 36 et prendre
le pouvoir et pour exercer sur la
société un réel contrôle de la classe
ouvrière et senna mars et à vous vous
êtes candidat du prg pas précisé pour la
formation politique que vous défendez
donc trois raisons la première c'est
voter pour une personne
j'ai grandi dans les yvelines je fais
partie du conseil de mon quartier et je
suis soucieux des préoccupations de mes
concitoyens je reflète la mixité
culturelle et ethnique de ma
circonscription et n'étant pas éteint de
l'institut de la société civile je ne
suis pas un politicien ou un financier
je suis à même de représenter les
intérêts de tous les français
deuxièmement voter pour des valeurs à
lui perd tous nos candidats en attaque
injuste dit sir vierge
nous accordons une grande importance à
la démocratie et nous souhaitons la
reconnaissance pleine et entière du vote
blanc le référendum d'initiative
populaire et le non cumul des mandats
nous avons une éthique en politique et
nous faisons appel au bon sens des
français pour qu'ils se rassemblent au
dessus du clivage afin que nous
retrouvions notre souveraineté nationale
et troisièmement voter pour des idées je
souhaite donc faire renouer les citoyens
avec la politique donner une vraie
représentativité aux dirigeants redonner
aux français la fierté d'être français
première thématique que nous allons
aborder à présent comme lors de la
première séquence et la question de la
sécurité j'aimerais vous entendre
les autres sur ce sujet les attentats
sont encore multipliés ces derniers
jours
on peut penser notamment à londres on a
encore appris la disparition de deux
français
encore aujourd'hui on va commencer avec
vous pour pour ce tour de table mathieu
rue fait part d'un nouveau souffle alors
c'est à dire que moi j'avais envie
d'accès déjà dans un premier temps ce
thème de la sécurité au niveau donc du
lien entre la population et les forces
de l'ordre
il est vrai que donc en tant que jeune
moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir de prendre le
monopole de la jeunesse ou presque j'ai
23 ans et c'est que j'ai grandi à
trappes
mais on est quand même sur leur première
ligne d'une relation qui se dégrade de
plus en plus avec les forces de l'ordre
j'ai envie de mettre en avant aussi les
relations avec la bac la brigade
anticriminalité sens sans forcément
créer une polémique
mais c'est à dire qu'il ya toute une
logique un petit peu de conflits
justement et qui a tendance un petit peu
a stigmatisé toujours la jeunesse et une
type de population précis et il ya une
sorte
j'allais dire le non droit et se situe
presque du côté des forces de l'ordre
c'est à dire que on a du mal nous en
tant que citoyens jeunes citoyens à se
défendre contre
la police était certes la police est là
pour nous protéger mais parfois qu'il
nous protège de la police j'ai envie d'y
où il ya du contrôle au faciès
ça c'est malheureusement une réalité on
part du principe ou à mon avis ce qui
serait préférable
il faudrait équiper les forces de
l'ordre de mécanisme d'enregistrement
audio et vidéo afin d'éviter tout
d'éviter toute forme de bavure je suis
aussi favorable à une réorganisation de
la police de proximité dans le sens
aujourd'hui
la brigade entre équipes anti
criminalité a le monopole du terrain et
qui peut donc se focalise principalement
sur donc lutter contre les trafics de
drogue etc
ils ont une sorte de ils ont une manière
d'agir avec une distanciation avec la
population y compris les jeunes il n'y a
pas de dialogue et c'est ça c'est
extrêmement problématique c'est à dire
que de ce niveau là je pense qu'il faut
vraiment réorganiser la police de
proximité avec une auto gestion de la
misère sociale je pense qu'aujourd'hui
la jeunesse au niveau local peut prendre
en main la sécurité des quartiers en
coopération avec les forces de l'ordre
bien entendu mais la brigade anti
criminalité n'a plus à mon avis la
légitimité suffisante pour pouvoir
intervenir sur le terrain et juste un
petit mot sur le terrorisme je pense que
les causes sont plus importantes que
c'est à dire qu ont certains trop
conséquence on s'attarde aux comment on
n'est plus dans un aspect de gestion de
réaction puisque d'anticipation les
causes sont avant tout sociale
économique et c'est la précarité c'est
le repli sur soi le communautarisme et
l'état qui a trop souvent tendance à
stigmatiser encore une fois un type de
population et qui créent et qui engendre
un processus de délitement du lien
social
n'hésitez pas les uns les autres à
réagir si vous voulez bien évidemment
interpeller les uns ou les autres
candidats pour échanger sur à propos de
vos idées c'est à vous à présent trop
loin oui c'est effectivement
l'insécurité est liée à la crise sociale
et politique et aussi à l'utilisation
que font les états de guerre partout sur
la planète à l'insécurité elle est pour
tout le monde du travail elle et elle
est pour tous les travailleurs qui ne
au risque au péril de leur vie sont
obligés de quitter leur pays
1 pour cause de guerre ou pour cause de
famine que les pays capitalistes ont
engendré et ces gens là l'un pour ces
gens-là l'insécurité les total combien
meurent en méditerranée chaque jour et
l'insécurité et les plus loin elle est
par tout pour tous les travailleurs et
les dans la peur de perdre son boulot
dès demain et la peur de perdre son
boulot demain fait que on travaille
aussi dans des conditions qui s'aggrave
de plus en plus partout - j'ai travaillé
pendant très longtemps de nombreuses
années dans un travail qui paraît sans
risque le travail de bureau dans des
caisses de retraite et bien danser les
mêmes caisses les conditions de travail
se sont tellement aggravé que oui il y a
de l'insécurité au travail on risque les
maladies professionnelles on risque la
dépression on risque ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le burn out 1 et combien là
il va y avoir le grand procès de
l'amiante nous dit on combien d'années
après combien il a fallu de milliers de
travailleurs qui meurent de dents après
les mines de l'amiante de tous je
discutais encore cet après midi avec un
habitant de trappes qui travaille dans
les travaux publics et qui me dit on à
pas on n'a rien contre
voilà on se casse le dos mais on respire
aussi des fumées nauséabondes
il pleure on creuse une tranchée il ya
l'électricité dedans on n'est pas
protégé
oui c'est ça l'insécurité et s'il n'y a
rien
les personnes dont l'état n'est nulle
part mlle fait c'est la police qui nous
en protège c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire pas reconduit par et j'ai bien les
intérêts des capitalistes lorsqu'on a
manifesté contre les lois
travail la question portait aussi sur la
question de la sécurité autour du
terrorisme pour revenir un petit peu aux
bases je passe avoue vincent fournier
j'imagine qu'il faut partager aussi une
partie exposée mais si on revient sur
cette thématique possible à ces friches
partage
les idées qui viennent d'être
développées par la camarade de lutte
ouvrière nous là pour nous la sécurité
d'abord l'ailé sociale cette chômage les
fermetures d'usinés ou les expulsions
locatives par exemple mais sur ce sujet
du terrorisme des guerres etc enfin on
constate aujourd'hui qu'il ya une
véritable déstabilisation au
moyen-orient dans une partie de
l'afrique
et ça ça a été causée par les guerres
des impérialistes des pays impérialistes
dont la france fait partie bien
évidemment et ça a causé des dégâts
considérables dans tous ces pays et
créer en plus des gros pain qu'on peut
que moi je qualifie de fascistes
clairement comme des thaïs familles qui
aujourd'hui commet des attentats dans le
monde entier
toutes les semaines voir tous les jours
parce que on parle beaucoup des
attentats en europe mais quand il ya un
attentat en syrie ou en irak on en parle
beaucoup moins et pourtant il y en a
peut-être encore plus et ça il faut pas
oublier qu si ces attentats c'est guerre
elles sont faites avec l'aide des
industriels français
ce que qui leur vend les armes en partie
c'est dassault c'est lagardère
donc le problème pour nous il viendra
aussi sénart pour le p r et geoffrey
rush juste après sur la sécurité je
pense qu'il faut deux actions une
préventive et curative la préventive
c'est en rappelant tout notre qui sont
sur des théâtres de guerre illégale nous
sommes s'engager au moyen-orient qui
nous avons détruit beaucoup de pays et
nous avons nous mêmes créé les
terroristes qui aujourd'hui nous
attaquent donc nous devons pour cela
sortir 2
l'otan qui nous rend suiveurs de cette
politique guerrière et qui nuit à nos
intérêts pour la partie curative nous
devons renforcer donc les moyens qui
sont données à nos forces de police
nous voyons que l'état d'urgence qui est
donc en place depuis le 14 novembre 2015
et qui a été renouvelée x x et
inefficace qui n'est pas appliquée il
faut que les mesures que nous prenions
soin plus ferme plus décisives et nous
devons reprendre le contrôle de ce qui
se passe aux frontières en termes de
transport de la circulation des
personnes
pour afin de pouvoir identifier mieux
identifier les gens qui viendraient
enfance pour commettre des actes
terroristes
on peut remarquer que maintenant nous
n'avons pris un ministère de la défense
nous avons un ministère des armées donc
ce qui laisse envisager donc encore pire
et nous des suites encore pire par
rapport à nos activités à l'étranger
donc le problème du terrorisme je ne
pense qu'il ne va pas sur aiguë de sitôt
si vous nous rejoignez un instant le
débat dans la 11e circonscription se
poursuit avec une partie des candidats
sur ce plateau nous parlons bien ce soir
de la 11e circonscription même si ce
n'est pas inscrit sur votre écran c'est
la 11e circonscription qui nous
intéresse dans les yvelines à présent
avec midi m n'avoir donc quelles sont
vos propositions en matière de sécurité
le regard aussi que vous portez sur
cette 11e circonscription on parle de 60
à 80 jeunes notamment et qui serait
partie ces derniers mois ces dernières
années vers la syrie par exemple comment
endiguer ce phénomène comment répondre
aussi à ce problème de société
alors moi je vais vous répondre sur la
sécurité et sur les attentats après vous
me posez des questions supplémentaires
- franchement ça m'intéresse pas ap de
ce qui m'intéresse en réponse moi je
pose des questions c'est quand même
souhaité écrit très bien
donc moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
sauver le pays savoir qu'il ya des
jeunes qui sont partis de trappes ou de
je ne sais quel quartier que vous que
vous citez ça m'intéresse pas du tout
moi ce que l'on est pas vraiment une
société d'organisation d'événements
problème justement problème c'est que on
nous a enlevé le débat sur le sociétal
et sur la société
et si la société française je veux dire
on peut se rejoindre tous là dessus à
des films différents niveaux elle est
profondément malade il va falloir
commencer par se soigner à la société
française
et puis après vous verrez que tout
s'enchaînera le boulot l'emploi quand
les gens sont mieux éduqués mieux
informés ils auront moins envie de faire
des bêtises de la délinquance vous
parlez de la police ou
d'aller dans sur des théâtres de guerre
ou de devenir sympathisants pour
manifester une opposition à cette
société qui n'accepte pas ou à ce
système qui est devenu très violent
c'est pas juste là l'islam les musulmans
les islamistes vous voyez madame n'est
pas musulmane elle pourrait elle dénonce
ce capitalisme
elle n'est pas parfaitement
donc elle peut vous pouvez avoir un
musulman à sa place qui va parler avec
la même verve mais qui ne se posera pas
avec les idées parce qu'on n'est pas
tous égaux au niveau 2
de notre tolérance ou de notre fragilité
et qu'il ira manifester son opposition
d'une autre manière
donc le problème fondamental c'est
d'abord les médias je ne vous sentez pas
personnellement visé mais les médias ne
sont pas libres il faut que les citoyens
français le sachent dans le temps on
avait un ministre de l'information un
ministre de propagande
aujourd'hui ce ministre là il est devenu
dans la tête de chaque journaliste
et puis vous savez les chaînes elles ont
un patron ça s'achète et se vend 1
lorsque vous avez beaucoup d'argent vous
avez vous acheté une chaîne vous ans
devenu l'actionnaire principal
vous développez donc directement
indirectement votre pensée votre
idéologie votre vision des choses et à
partir de là les choses ne peuvent que
mal se passer
les informations que nous avons en
boucle sur les chaînes les journaux les
radios sur toute source d'information de
crise au complot se sont mal d'être un
lieu plus synthétique parce que je vais
vous repassez vous n'aurez plus de temps
après pour pour voulu exprimer parfois
l'un et je rappelle que même que vous
pouvez vous exprimer librement sur ce
plateau
merci beaucoup donc les informations
qu'on nous donne
elles sont mâchés prémâché servi ce
n'est pas des informations brutes
on n'a pas tout dit toutes les
informations le savez tous les jours
rien qu'en france vous avez 300
informations entre les faits divers les
faits politiques etc mais il ya des gens
qui décident si on fait passer tel ou
tel dizaine 25 informations ou les
autres donc le peuple sera de toute
façon orientés dans un sens ou dans un
autre
pour finir la police pareil la police
faut imaginer les policiers il se
réveille pas le matin ils phrases et
puis les 10 g on va se donner une
mission tiens si je partais dans quel
quartier contrôlé des gens ou voir si
tout se passe bien qu'ils sont aux
ordres
faut dire les choses comme il faut ils
sont aux ordres ils ont aucun pouvoir
aucune marge de manoeuvre
on leur dit allez là bas allez ici ou
après en normes et des sanctions parce
qu'ils n'ont pas assez contrôlés ils ont
pas assez en cinq minutes après 105
seulement pardon vous êtes à cinq
minutes de temps de parole cinq secondes
je pense que je vais m'arrêter là allez
voilà pour pouvoir réagir ensuite après
l'écart se creuse sinon entre vous vous
étiez certaines choses qui avait été
bien sûr principalement au niveau
médiatique c'est à dire que souvent
quand on parle de terrorisme on va
parler de religion va parler d'islam
franchement je pense que locaux le
problème beaucoup plus complexe que cela
le réduire au simple rêve à la simple
question religieuse ça n'a aucun sens il
faut réfléchir au problème de fond c'est
un long processus il ya des causes
sociologiques
je pense qu'avant tout il ya dès qu il
ya des facteurs de désintégration
sociale les obstacles culturels ne sont
pas des problèmes mais les délitement
social et les inégalités sociales et les
injustices sociales historiques sont des
vrais problèmes qui sont assimilés
incorporé par par une frange de la
population qui est marginalisés et
qu'ils entrent réaction comment dire
envers un état qui vis-à-vis desquels
ils vont tenir responsables de leur
situation actuelle il ya tout un
cheminement à effectuer et il ne faut
pas prendre les
les choses comme telle la vraie
différence je veux dire la vraie vie ce
n'est pas l'avis de bfm tv c'est à dire
que c'est beaucoup plus complexe que
cela ce n'est pas une question de
religion c'est beaucoup plus complexe et
yacine amarres pour l'upm vincent
fournier pour le npa
si vous souhaitez réagir vous avez un
peu plus d'une minute de retard par
rapport aux autres sinon on va avancer
sur les thématiques pas sur ce sujet
donc surtout ici je pouvais cette
émission si je peux faire c'est parce
que c'est vrai que vous vous sinon vous
allez passer la soirée à vous demander à
réagir les uns par rapport aux autres si
je peux permettre une petite remarque
sur ce plateau il n'y a pas trop de
différence
là on à moi j'aurais bien aimé réagir
c'est le plateau précédent que j'ai bien
aux goodies il y avait plein de choses
qui m'ont fait bondir ici bon
franchement j'ai pas envie d'arrêter les
collègues quand ils développent leurs
pensées mais le tableau précédent oui là
j'avais envie de bondir
malheureusement vous nous avait séparés
en deux plateaux voilà faut faire
maintenant avec ce concours donne la
règle qui a été donné pour l'ensemble
des candidats bien évidemment vous le
voyez vous même sur ce plateau en étant
présent on ne peut pas accueillir plus
de six personnes simultanément et il
faut respecter l équité l'équité c'est
la recommandation du csa et vous le
savez si je vais vous passez la parole
si je peux juste terminé de m'adresser
aux téléspectateurs vous le savez la
règle qui est fixé et qui édité par le
csa c'est celle de l'équité nous avons
au delà puisque nous basons sur
l'égalité et nous allons même au delà de
l'équité quasiment toutes les formations
en même temps de parole sur les
différentes circonscriptions que nous
couvrons je vous laisse à réagir et à
fond avant sinon l'émission va se
terminer mais je sais pas ce que
j'exprime et je rappelle aussi que vous
avez une carte blanche après pour
choisir le sujet que vous voulez mettre
on a juste sur ce qu'a dit monsieur fin
il n'y a pas trop de différence de
constat
ça reste à voir mais en tout cas moi
j'ai cru comprendre que vous avez voté
front national au premier tour et c'est
pas du tout ce qu'on défend nous on
cherche pas on cherche pas à diviser les
travailleurs mais à les rassembler donc
pour moi il ya une énorme différence
entre nous c'est très léger comme
argument si c'est une différence entre
un travailleur travailleurs que vous
dites que moi ou le pré nationale 2 ne
défends pas c'est c'est super léger
comme argument
il aurait pas eu ce que vous venez dire
c'est à dire que vous vous défendez les
travailleurs et donc moi ou le front
national nous ne défendons pas pour être
tout à fait honnête vous aurait dû dire
pourquoi j'ai appelé à voter front
national je ne fais pas partie du front
national je ne suis pas le candidat du
front national il ya une vidéo
je suis ici je suis moi même donc
blogueurs tout le monde peut me trouvais
un peu partout mon site et mais dit
n'avoir point com et j'ai fait une vidéo
la veille du premier tour explicative
sur le pourquoi j'ai fait le choix de
voter front national
c'était très tôt pour penser à ce qu'on
sait c'est que la vidéo jarry vous
interrompt ses longs parce que monsieur
grandjean par les spectateurs à suivre à
suivre cette vidéo vous avez publié sur
internet ce sera le mieux c'est elle
avait la veille du premier tour j'ai été
censuré pendant quinze jours de facebook
à plusieurs reprises pour m'éviter
justement là de donner une consigne de
vote
monsieur mélenchon il n'y a aucun
journaliste qui veut parler de ces
affaires passées par ce que il en a bien
profité quand il était conseiller
général et réutiliser des juges je suis
là de régis interrompt vous êtes à plus
de six minutes tente pas respecté les
règles elles ont été fixées
si vous ne les acceptez pas vous n'aviez
pas l'obligation de venir sur ce plateau
j'ai oublié de jacques serre est prêt je
renvoie interplay je réponds je renvoie
comme je vous ai dit soit vous
synthétiser son renvoi vers la vidéo
vous avez publié ce que vous avez faire
mentionner votre votre votre blog dont
j'ai notamment parlé de musique soit
plus vous aurez dû me laisser finir nous
allons voir à présent les temps de
paroles qui s'affichent et pour ne pas
pénaliser les candidats je ne vous
répondrai pas nous allons voir les
différents taux de paroles qui vont
s'afficher
et vous avez pris beaucoup d'avancé par
rapport aux autres candidats
si on peut juste passer à la seconde
thématique et je préciserai qu'à une
petite erreur qui a été fait sur les
différentes photos des candidats si on
peut la corriger mehdi et noir notamment
yacine amar les deux photos ont été
intervertis je le précise pour qu'il n'y
ait pas d'erreur sur ce plateau je leur
dis donc on affichera plus ça et je leur
donnerai les temps bien évidemment aux
uns et aux autres pour vous puissiez
vous positionnez voilà ceci est en fait
l'éducation à présent c'est l'autre
thématique qui nous intéresse on va
commencer avec vous pour lutte ouvrière
le regard les propositions que vous
portez en matière d'éducation va
rejoindre un petit peu peut-être qui a
été dit sur le plateau de la sécurité de
la prévention de l'ado personnes les
plus démunies il faut faire une
éducation finalement renforcer
l'éducation pour éviter d'arriver sur
des questions de délinquance peut être
aussi c'était pas du tout mon thème
c'était pas du tout comme ça qui
envisageait l'été comme ça comment vous
les ayez par une question
l'éducation c'est ça revient 1
régulièrement on fait une réforme pour
masquer la pauvreté de 2 du système et
de et de l'éducation
1 et de la misère de l'éducation
nationale l'a à nouveau macron nous dit
à ses formidables
on va faire des classes de cp de 12 est
de 12 élèves alors il ne précise pas
qu'il va augmenter les moyens
au contraire il dit c'est dans les zep
alors ça tombe bien parce que le
gouvernement davant avait déjà réduit
les les zones d'éducation prioritaire à
peau de chagrin donc finalement celui
que cela lui coûtera pas grand chose et
c'est encore une fois du vent nous parle
de réformes
alors on va réintroduire le grec et le
latin en fin de mois le latin je n'ai
rien contre au contraire mais
ce n'est pas intéressant quand
donnera-t-on à l'éducation nationale et
pour l'éducation des jeunes dans son
ensemble et à tous les niveaux
pas seulement pour les classes des beaux
quartiers
mais pour toutes les écoles qu'elles
soient primeur qu'elle soit secondaire
ou aux universités et voire même la
formation professionnelle après tout au
long de la vie et la culture les moyens
nécessaires que l'on peut prendre quand
même en économisant sérieusement sur les
cadeaux qu'on fait aux entreprises
on passe à présent la parole à présent
par don pour pour l'upm sur vos
propositions sur l'éducation
donc concernant l'éducation on peut voir
que toutes les réformes qui ont été ces
dernières décennies ont considérablement
dégradées le niveau des élèves à l'école
donc je pense qu'il est important que
vous adressent la barre qu'on donne plus
de moyens aux enseignants pour mieux
former nos enfants que on implique les
parents on responsabilités vis-à-vis de
leurs enfants pour les faire travailler
faire faire leurs devoirs pour que tout
ne soit pas à la charge de nombre de
l'éducation nationale il faut donc leur
redonner le goût à l'effort et à la
persévérance je pense que c'est une des
choses les plus importantes qui s'est
perdue depuis ces dernières décennies
il faut qu'une neutralité
dans dans les cours dans
dans l'enseignement qui est fait donc à
l'école en termes surtout d'éducation
civique et d'histoire-géographie
favoriser la mixité sociale en arrêtant
de faire ces écoles d'élite où tout le
monde se rassemble avec donc une
sélection
et puis l'idée des écoles de plus soit
des rebelles qui engendre du coût des
écarts de niveaux considérables c'est
pas quelque chose qui sont dans les
valeurs de notre république je pense
qu'il faut améliorer cet écart il faut
le réduire
il faut assurer aussi la paix dans nos
établissements
on a vu dans l'actualité beaucoup
d'événements qui sont quand même très
inquiétant en termes de sécurité dans
les écoles entre les élèves mais aussi
entre élèves et enseignants faisant
souvent aussi montré que des personnes
de l'extérieur aux établissements entrée
dans les écoles pour faire pour régler
des comptes et donc il faut vraiment
renforcer les moyens pour que ces
choses-là n'arrivent plus à savon
versements pourront ni du côté du npa
concernant l'éducation peut-être en
revenant aussi sur ce qui peut-être
circonscription et peut-être les
difficultés qui sont rencontrés écoutez
sur l'éducation nationale pour nous le
problème il est le même que dans tous
les services publics que ce soit à la
pause salle sncf et edf ont supprimé
depuis des années des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois donc après il n'y a
pas de surprise
les moyens sont pas là donc ça se
dégrade j'entendais tout à l'heure sur
le premier plateau enfin
une espèce de faux débats entre la
semaine de quatre jours la semaine de
cinq jours pour nous le sujet il n'est
pas loin le sujet il est con qu'on
supprime des emplois qu on ferme des
classes sas multiplie les fermetures de
classes en primaire notamment
d'ailleurs il ya des luttes
régulièrement il ya beaucoup de parents
d'élèves qui sont préoccupés qu'ils vont
parfois jusqu'à jusqu'à occuper des
classes pour regarder les ouvertures de
certaines classes
et voilà donc évidemment il faut créer
des emplois il faut recréer les emplois
qu'on a supprimé et il faut même ancré
nouveau puisque pour nous des classes
enfin moi j'ai l'exemple ma fille à la
rentrée en maternelle on m'a dit 28
élèves dans sa classe
pour nous ça c'est pas possible il faut
il faut démultiplier les classes et donc
donner les moyens et recruter des
enseignants et des assistants par
exemple dans les maternelles en nombre
nature est fait oui c'est une question
de moyens bien entendu mais je pense que
c'est un peu plus encore une fois pour
approfondir c'est à dire que c'est aussi
une question d'engagement d'état
d'esprit un petit peu des pouvoirs
publics aujourd'hui d'essayer de briser
les mécanismes de reproduction sociale
on va par études ont peur et actualiser
les thèses de bourdieu etc
voilà je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya
quand même une frange de la population
qui est qui qui donc issus de la
catégorie dominante ou des classes
dominantes qui eux en plus de chances de
réussir
et ça c'est quelque chose vraiment qu'il
faut essayer non pas d'éradiquer mais
d'endiguer dans le sens où il faut
donner la chance à tout le monde
il faut accorder une équité et complet
pour la jeunesse des classes populaires
donc
je pense qu'il faut valoriser des plus
jeune âge le talent de chacun
il faut pas préparé une société de
salariat sauce il faut essayer de
dépasser un petit peu cette logique de
préparer de futurs de futurs salariés de
dépasser un petit peu tout cette logique
de se dire que oui je vais me trouver un
poste une entreprise etc
faut vraiment essayer de révéler les
talents essayer de mettre en invente le
potentiel de chacun et je pense qu'il
faut faire confiance aussi aux
professeurs le professeur souvent sont
là par vocation
ils sont capables d'amener les jeunes
vers vers la réussite et de les
considérer au travers de leur potentiel
et pas uniquement d'un degré
d'employabilité plein de bachelier s'est
blessé bien mais après voilà ça sert à
quoi dans le fond je pense qu'il est
nécessaire vraiment de donner la chance
à chacun de pouvoir exprimer son talent
un petit peu en dehors donc des débuts
carcan du salariat et c'est peut-être de
donner plus la chance à des futurs
entrepreneurs
moi je suis aussi favorable dès le
collège à l'apprentissage des sciences
sociales
je pense que la sociologie aujourd'hui à
son mot à dire et je pense aussi que
pour les jeunes issus des classes
populaires
il est important ou au travers donc de
l'apport de la sociologie de prendre
conscience de leur propre situation de
relativiser et d'essayer de d'être armé
face à une société qui est souvent
injuste souvent inégale et d'autant plus
quand on vient des classes populaires
ce sera alors à près de votre carte
blanche aux aux uns et aux autres tout
d'abord remédier m d'avoir sur cette
question d'éducation
je vais vous demander d'être concis
puisque vous aviez de la vence d'accord
bon sur l'éducation nationale par et là
il ya beaucoup de mensonges beaucoup de
manipulations là on peut débattre
éternellement
2 pourquoi ça marche pas à l'école
pourquoi on est mal classé au classement
internationaux
les solutions je vois bien que en face
monsieur du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste l'extrême gauche ou
madame de l'extrême gauche tous ces
partis ça a été perméable au travers du
temps y arrivant des représentants qui
ont gouverné
madame je suis désolé non non non non je
suis communiste alors quelques
communistes eux sont allés mais sait il
était due par tous c'est ce que je viens
de dior il décrit par voyez vous savez
ça parle à personne de parler de
trotskisme etc
vous avez des communistes au pouvoir
je suis communiste peut intéresser
effectifs d'avant krach sûrement temps
de parole mais on dit moi je disait pas
le contraire de vous j'ai dit que
l'extrême gauche a d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est retrouver un joueur
bien sûr que s'interrompt et se met face
à cette discussion passé au plateau
j'étais au gouvernement donc je ne sais
pas si je peux si je peux juste répondre
à ce qui a été dit je rappelle que les
candidats qui sont face à vous
représenter le npa et lutte ouvrière y
présentera les partis communistes ce
sont des franges des différentes
formations politiques
donc voilà ils vous ont répondu vous
avez également répondu je vous demandais
en 30 secondes parce que je voulais dire
vous avez beaucoup d'avant sur 30
paroles de parler de vos propositions en
matière d'éducation de regard que vous
portez aussi sur ce qui est proposé dans
un premier temps par le maire de mâcon
parce que si vous êtes élu vous aller
siéger à l'assemblée et vous devrez
voter des lois
donc parce que j'ai été interpellé tout
à l'heure je reviens moi je combats
cette extrême gauche
cette gauche et ce après par extension
on a vu avec macro que tout est
perméable le centre droite républicaine
qui s'appelle républicaine les
républicains se rejoignent sur tous les
thèmes dont notre monde il y avait le
front national
et puis tous les rebelles qui se sont
agglutinés autour
moi je suis contre cette gauche là et
cette extrême gauche ils ont gouverné
par madame taubira et leurs idées ils
ont été largement présent surtout dans
l'éducation nationale qui est un les
affaires sow qui est un désastre dans
que l'éducation nationale si c'est un
désastre c'est pas parce que il
il ya beaucoup d'élèves par classe c'est
pas comme préconise monsieur comme ils
ont toujours préconisé qu'il faut
embaucher en masse pour réduire le
nombre d'élèves tout ça c'est des
bêtises vous avez en afrique des classes
où ils 135i 110 x 40 font prenez
n'importe quel quand ils arrivent en
france cette phrase il maîtrise mieux
les mathématiques que n'importe quel
français du même âge ils sont au minimum
trilingue
alors que la majorité madame bien parler
du latin mais c'est vrai la majorité des
français ce n'est pas je suis désolé je
disais tout à l'heure vous êtes gentils
en deux temps par les quatre minutes
c'est pas possible je ne parlais pas
fini c'est votre droit mais nous
n'interviendrons pas sur la carte
blanche
même le sur le français que les français
les français ne maîtrisent pas leur
langue totalement ceci était une
catastrophe ça ne vient pas du nombre
d'élèves par classe comme je viens de
vous dire la proposition c'est arrêter
cette hypocrisie
ça devient l'éducation nationale c'est à
peu près moi je vous dis non c'est comme
à l'époque les militaires c'est qu'on
avait en algérie est la chose qui valait
je suis désolé on avait les militaires
français qui nous allons casser en
algérie et des autres cartes blanches ou
qu'elles vont pourrait pas participer je
vous le dis vous avez trop de temps de
parole par apple de l'éducation
nationale il semble que le message a été
entendu nous passons maintenant au
caveau carte blanche aux uns et aux
autres on va commencer avec vos pauvres
pour lutter vous êtes le plus en retard
vous avez plus d'une minute si vous
souhaitez développer un sujet quel sujet
souhaitez vous mettre en avant lorsque
vous lorsque vous serez élu voilà tout
simplement si vous êtes alors moi de
sujet qui m'intéresse c'est l'industrie
donc car je suis ingénieur et chef
d'entreprise je pense aussi que dans
notre circonscription on a beaucoup de
grandes entreprises et de plus petites
c'est un bassin donc on peut voir que
nous avons inventé le concorde le tgv le
gsm on a fait le minitel précurseur
d'internet et on peut voir que bas
depuis sept depuis ces temps là rien ne
sort rien la france ne brille plus comme
elle brillé avant et on peut se demander
pourquoi pourquoi nous avons fermé notre
dernier haut-fourneau pourquoi nous
vendons nos cristallerie et pourquoi nos
usines textiles tout le savoir faire
français est en train de mourir petit à
petit depuis une trentaine d'années et
je pense qu'il est important de se poser
la question pourquoi en dehors du fait
que nous avons un euro qui est trop fort
pour nous qui finalement nous rend pas
compétitifs et justement nous détruit à
petit feu il ya aussi donc le
les règles du jeu qui sont asymétriques
donc n'importe quel pays quelle personne
de notre pays peut racheter des terroirs
de racheter des entreprises en france on
a vu avec alstom dernièrement mais l'un
vers ce n'est pas possible je ne pense
pas que je puisse s'acheter un fleuron
technologique aux états unis ou en chine
donc il faut qu'on instaure de plus de
protectionnisme nous pour protéger
justement nos industries et nos
travailleurs les gens qui travaillent
donc et une titraille notre entreprise
et on peut voir que les lois aujourd'hui
qui sont imposées par l'union européenne
nous empêche de faire ceci
puisqu'il ya la libre circulation des
capitaux des marchandises et des
personnes
donc aujourd'hui comme il n'ya pas
d'harmonisation fiscale ni social c'est
simple une en bronze les grandes
entreprises qu'est ce qu'elles font
elles ouvrent leurs usines en europe de
l'est ou ailleurs encore plus loin elles
ont leurs chaises leur siège au
luxembourg ou en irlande
et elle paye du coup 2 % d'impôts et on
voit que ben ça ça détruit le tissu l'ap
les usines on a une qui ferme par jour
on a 1000 personnes qui passent en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté à peu près
par jour plus le nom de toutes les 14000
suicides par an on va retrouver en
france on voit que de les traiter dans
lesquelles nous sommes
nous sommes rentrés contre l'avis des
français en 2005 qui ont voté non au
référendum nous nuisent nuisent
profondément à notre économie est un
sport de plus en plus de chômage on voit
que depuis la courbe ne cesse de monter
monter et n'a pas fini de monter sans
fard ni votre carte blanche moi je
voulais aborder un sujet qui est assez
peu abordé mon avis dans les médias au
vu de la gravité de la situation
c'est la politique criminelle en ce
moment tchétchénie contre de répression
contre la communauté homosexuelle
ce qu'il faut savoir quand même que tu
vois ça fait le cinéma habituel ça je
suis demandé de laisser à la 84e par
l'épreuve excusez moi je remets mon
juillet qui soufflait en france n'a
aucune preuve c'est juste si vous
répétez si cela plaît s'il vous plaît je
vais vous demander ce qu'ils valent et d
interrompre je vais vous demander de
quitter le bateau si vous ne laissez pas
parler les autres candidats ont eux
mêmes demandé ce que voulait quitter
alors si vous voulez pas laisser parler
les autres candidats est ce que ces
quartiers là que deux sur place voilà
moi j'ai laissé parler les autres
candidats je vais vous demander de
quitter passe aussi la dernière fois que
je pouvais me demandait si j'avais un
problème avec les combats se cogner sur
le calaisis l'homosexuel son féminisme
vous pouvez retourner s'il vous plaît je
vous laisse faire votre carte blanche à
l'élite ce sujet j'ai donc avec vos
mensonges
oui bien sûr donc il ya aucune aucun
problème mais il ya une noire suit la
plaie je vous demande de quitter le
plateau la théorie du complot
allez donc il ya une véritable politique
de répression y compris des tchétchènes
qui sont arrivés en france dernièrement
et il faut qu'il y ait un effort
là-dessus du gouvernement français pour
aider bien sûr à ce qu'ils viennent plus
facilement et ce qu'ils aient un visa
plus rapidement et fascine c'est quand
même une gravité
c'est des camps de véritables deux camps
de concentration même si c'est
certainement là c'est énorme
le parquet estime c'est juste pas
possible
s'il vous plaît je vous demande à tous
alors soit vous interrompez soit nous
rendons l'antenne et le débat va
s'interrompre et ce sera inégal pour
l'ensemble des candidats très bien et
bien écoutez je vous remercie d'avoir
suivi ce débat pour les téléspectateurs
visiblement que vous ne respectez pas
nous allons être obligés d'interrompre
serait débat c'est donc la fin de cette
édition et et je vous donnerai du temps
de parole dans notre prochaine édition
du journal
elles nous font des interviews avec vous
vous aurez du temps de parole équilibré
à moins que monsieur m noir quitte le
plateau et permettre aux autres de
s'exprimer
vous ne souhaitez pas quitté je laisse
pas dire de bêtises c'est est ce que
vous pouvez laisser les autres parler
comme les autres bêtises sur le salaire
salaire jamais vu ajoute que sont les
excès qui ont régi nous pouvons couper
les micros parce que ce n'est pas
audible
si en régie nous pouvons couper
voilà si vous pouvez couper les micros
des intervenants vous voyez bien bien
évidemment agréé comme il se doit toutes
nos excuses pour ce débordement en
plateau vous le voyez ce candidat
pénalise les autres candidats nous avons
joué le jeu et donner la parole à tous
les candidats ils se sont tous exprimés
sur ce plateau certains noms alain en
l'occurrence au sort n'a pas respecté le
jeu je m'engage auprès des autres nous
allons vous interviewez ensuite et nous
passons ces séquences dans le journal
veuillez nous voyait nous en excuser
sauf que le reportage pourra pas être
diffusé puisque nous devons arrêter cela
pour les diffusions à partir du week-end
voilà donc ça ça passera dans le journal
de demain demain jeudi
vous aurez du temps de parole pour
équilibrer je suis vraiment déçu but au
comportement de cet invité et qui
pénalisent les autres merci de nous
avoir suivis néanmoins génériques
[Musique]